then
good morning everybody my name is david
smith and i am the legal advisor for the
purposes of the uh ongoing review
um as i say first of december uh 2020
it's now 9 42. this is a sitting or baby
district council licensing subcommittee
which is sitting to review
a premises license under section 51 of
the licensing act 2003.
in respect of the caffeine lounge 14
boron gate shopping center sudbury co 10
to eg
for the purposes of of today and has
been the case uh with regards to the
previous uh hearings of the
representations um the review is going
to is being um
governed if i can put it that way by the
licensing act 2003 hearings regulations
2005.
i mentioned that especially with regards
to
[Applause]
rule 15 right of attendance assistance
and representation and rule 16
representations and supporting
information
uh before i proceed further i know
you've all heard this before but i will
now be making some uh or give you a
narrative with regards to how uh the
hearing is going to be recorded
i remind everybody that everybody
present as this meeting will be
broadcast live to youtube
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and the possible
use of those sound recordings for
webcasting and or trading purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may film record photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
and once again for the purpose of this
particular meeting i'm going to just
remind everybody about virtual meeting
etiquette
first of all please ensure that
microphones are muted when you are not
speaking
secondly that you do not interrupt other
speakers
thirdly that if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
and finally you will be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair so i
would respectfully ask everybody to wait
their turn
before i hand you over to the chairman
of the review hearing which is
councillor newman um given that this is
the third day for this review hearing i
would just like to remind
all those present
with regards to uh regulation 23 of the
licensing regulations that the hearing
will take the form of a discussion led
by the authority and cross-examination
shall not be permitted unless the
authority considers that
cross-examination is required for it to
consider the representations application
or notice as the case may require that's
just a gentle reminder to everybody
present of that regulation uh thank you
very much everybody i now hand you over
to councillor mark newman who is the
chairman of this review hearing
thank you david um welcome to everybody
to the licensing subcommittee and
welcome especially to everyone watching
on youtube uh we'll go to apologies for
absence have we got any karen
did not receive chair
uh um uh declarations of interest do we
have any of those
uh councillor beer i think we got one
from councillor beer
well just to remind um
members
and the public and i did state this at
the beginning of the
first day
that i i am a member of favorite
district council planning committee and
as such did take part in
the planning
um
approval that was given for the um
licensing of the lounge uh so it's just
a
pint to clarify so that one's quite
clear okay thank you peter that's the
only involvement
okay thank you very much right um i'll
introduce uh the committee members i'm
mark newman i'm chairman um sue would
you like to introduce yourself morning
counselor sue carpendale
uh councillor peter beer great corner
thank you
i'd like to introduce the officers in
attendance uh a legal advisor
david
your mike's not on
thank you mr chair uh david with that
legal advice for the purposes of the
review hearing
okay a licensed officer another david
david price licensing officer
uh uh assistant manager emma
good morning chair yes emma rich bell
assistant manager food safety and
licensing
uh governance officer karen
good morning everyone karen say
governance uh a monitoring officer emma
emily sorry
thank you chan good morning everyone
emily your monitoring officer for baby
district council
uh have we got any other offices
all present
okay um
could the appicon introduce yourself
which would be trevor
good morning everybody i'm the applicant
and my name's trevor cresswell
okay and the prime minister's premise's
license and his representative is that
david david dodds would you like
introduce yourself good morning members
i'm david dads d a double d s and i
represent the premise license holder
okay oh who are you with me virtually uh
on the screen next to me
okay thank you uh suffolk constabulary
yes good morning i'm sharon betts palmer
licensing officer for suffolk
constabulary
okay uh environmental protection offices
good morning chair i'm chris cornish
senior environmental protection officer
yeah and have you got some uh you got
some witnesses or help there uh good
morning i'm a joint representation with
mr cornish james buckingham environment
assistant manager
okay thank you
anyone else nah right
planning enforcement officer
thank you chair good morning simon
bailey from the planning enforcement
team
thank you very much um other persons
doug darlington here
sorry um
mr dorington um had to go to the doctors
again but uh he may arrive later chair
okay
thank you
right
right we'll move back to the meeting
what was adjourned so it's back to the
environmental protection officer uh
chris would you like to take off take up
where you left off please mr chairman
i've raised my hand i wondered if i
could just seek a point of clarification
please okay yes baby dads yeah we've
just been introduced um
and and i don't agree
um there's been a change that james
buckingham is a joint
in effect
interested party or responsible
authority we agreed at the outset
that chris cornish is um the
representative he's made the
representation him and i had an
opportunity to speak
and we were told at the outset of this
now three days that he would be calling
someone i think called les
and james as witnesses should they be
required to answer questions
um there is no uh joint um uh parties
we've heard now from environment health
and it's going to questions i believe
james is here to answer any questions
should the need arise um so i'm just
clarifying what the status is of james
because i don't expect to hear from
james um
another representation
legal david
well perhaps uh mr buckingham just
confirmed that he's here to
um clarify or
clarify any points
or what his role is please
um well i'd defer to the legal advice i
mean the representation that we
submitted was was has always been a
joint representation written jointly by
myself and chris um i've said this
throughout the meeting i don't know what
was agreed between um
what mr dad says it was agreed
um it's really a point of law i would
have thought whether i'm entitled to
make a representation or not um
my understanding of the uh regulations
um there's nothing i've said right from
day one i'm a representative and i would
like to give evidence um so it's really
over to mr smither and i would have
thought mr price to make a decision on
that based on the law and advise the
committee
thank you can i just clarify from
licensing at the very start of this
review were any names provided and given
to the
subcommittee as to who will be
making representations on behalf of
environmental protection
uh chair all three were names were given
um at the start when the representation
was at before the hearing
um so james buckingham
liz king and chris cornish were all
given at the start of the um a at the
start of the hearing and b
when um
the attendance notice was provided
okay uh david dad do you want to come
back yes mr chairman you we can go back
to the recording we have it if need be
um i i was told that we had the three
officers we know that uh chris cornish
is the lead member and he's made the
representations uh i asked what
witnesses you remember we had quite a
lot of discussion about that
um that they we had not been notified
have not received their written
statements so then they um they came
together to say well we've we've
co-written it
i then had a
conversation with mr cornish to agree
um what witnesses and who's being called
he said that he would um have james and
les
because they had done some observations
and they've made contributions to the
evidence and there will be therefore
answering questions that was what was
agreed because i raised the issue about
the the witness statements and who had
signed it whose was it
in relation to where we are we've heard
from environmental health we're now to
ask points of clarification
and questions
james buckingham doesn't get another
opportunity to introduce and introduce
new evidence unless he's asked questions
that is the position of law there's no
changing positions on day three
and i'm going to be quite firm about it
um mr sherman as far as my note is
concerned we're still in the process of
the representations being made by mr
cornish he got to page 36 of uh the pack
um with regards to the uh who was going
to be speaking on behalf of the
environmental protection i think you've
got the answer from from mr price i
think this is day three
you may want to consider let's making
some further progress with regards to
today's hearing please
okay um
david das can we carry
on well it's a matter for you mr
chairman but uh it's about fairness and
at the end of the day you know how many
people are speaking for environmental
health but we'll carry on and i've
raised the point your legal advisor i
think he's incorrect in law but we'll
crack on and um and if it becomes a
point later on i'll deal with it
okay well um we say i've got phase 36
here so um can you environmental officer
start off carry on from page 36 please
thank you chair um i think really um
we've heard about the
history
we've heard about
the investigation and i just want to
bring the committee's attention
to specifically the evidence we've got
the recordings three hours
30 minutes of recordings that are
snapshots
of the time periods that are being
described by the residences when they're
disturbed
um he's not we don't ask for every
record we can't sit there for
weeks listening to a week and a half of
recordings it's not reasonable and it's
corroborating the truth of what we're
being told
um it's if you look at the 26th on the
sorry on the summary submitted with the
evidence
that's just disappeared apologies
um if you look at the summary officer
recording summary uh in particular the
dates of
the 26th and the first
it's all night they are snapshots of all
night
of what was heard noises from a busy bar
but it's not just weekends there are
various scales of noise levels of noise
with midweek until 3 50 in the morning
on the early hours of the thursday the
30th
uh 2 30 in the morning on the early
hours of the
early hours of the 27th
so this goes on every week
we know the noise the majority of the
noise noises being created on premises
police and environmental protection
officers have witnessed the groups of
people standing outside on the ropes off
area the
block paved the area to the rear of the
great eastern road doors
um the chief superintendent mills he
visited on the 15th of august at
midnight witnessed groups of people some
intoxicated
um the dps at the time had to tell
people to be quiet because the police
were there on a couple of occasions i'm
sorry to interrupt
um
is it yeah yeah sorry it's canceled a
bit um we seem to have lost counselor
cartondale
um i can't say no i'm here can you not
hear me
i i
yes
um
yeah so the evidence that the police
witnessing on various nights ourselves
witnessing on nights the recordings all
corroborate what the six residents
including the resident from cornard road
have reported it corroborates the
plausibility of what they're saying
um
they're staying open
using their light hours not on occasion
but regularly during the time of
monitoring in july and august
um
this is the show games
not host tournaments but to show games
on a tv no different to a sports bar
for me
it's plain
for the premises to see what's going on
outside their back doors
mr ward during his discussion with eps
during his discussion with
uh superintendent mills was aware
of keeping people quiet
maybe they're unsuccessful
but that discussion has never been had
um so
they they wasn't following their
planning conditions as they're planning
this in their license and always
management policies they should all be
doing or they're unsuccessful
in doing that it wasn't possible in the
way that that premises were being run at
that time
in what the customers that they were
attracting at that time
um to put that into comparison we had
two similar complaints in sudbury of
similar noise out the front of premises
on the street and in their outside areas
neither them complaints went past the
first letter stage
in fact one of those premises even went
to the press to announce their strong
measures
of how they were going to deal with it
both both had a couple of complaints not
as many complaints as this property
this is what licensed premises do on a
day-in day-out basis
sorry mr coyne i think mr dads have got
a point of order or
yes mr chairman i have we've we are i i
didn't interrupt when the officer
started talking about the evidence of
the police he should be talking about
his own representation and his own
evidence not summarizing
or interpreting other people's evidence
i didn't interrupt at that point but i
must interrupt at the point where he's
talking about now two other premises
what happened to them and how what
enforcement action what stage that's not
in the papers can he stick to the
representation that he's made he's
allowed to amplify it but he's not
allowed to add anything no mr chairman
it's not fair he's in effect summarizing
and pulling in everyone else to try to
bolster his own representation which is
weak
okay okay i mr can you still do respect
chair we're talking about standard
industry practice this isn't new or
amplifying or ambushing anybody this is
what every licensed premises does and in
terms of the police evidence we're in
contact with the police we meet on a
monthly basis on the anti-social
behaviour panel in sudbury we talk about
areas and on that point i'll bring that
up as well
this great eastern road never come up as
an area where we were getting
anti-social behaviour and noise
disturbances uh prior to this this
premises opening
the evidence is all part of evidence
that i hold i had them discussions when
we're trying to establish what's
happening at the premises we discuss
with our partner agencies we work in
partnership
so it's not amplifying this is all stuff
that's been considered i've included two
statements as a snapshot in my represent
in the representation of environmental
detection
and i'm not making a representation it
is environmental protection making
representation we're a named entity in
the act and the guidance yes
it's not for individual officers to make
representations it's not the health and
safety of work where individual officers
take action it's the
section that i am employed and
authorized by
i have no objection to the officer
saying anything he wants as long as it's
within the representation he's made and
which he can amplify nothing new he's
referring to the police's evidence which
he ought not to be doing
um to amplify what he's doing but he's
talking about two other premises and
that they only got to a first stage i
have got no evidence of that i can't
test it today on day three it's new you
shouldn't be introducing it he should be
speaking to his representation which
you've got in front of you and we've all
read
all right mr could you stick to that so
with the
so we can carry on please
well actually i was literally in the
last couple of sentences so yeah okay
now thanks for that
we'll give it up as the further
interruptions carry on
all right
thank you very much for your report
right well now we will move
thank you thanks very much we will now
move to questions and um
david dads would you like to start your
questioning
yes mr chairman can i just raise the
point i i was under the impression
that last time we left we finished
uh
uh chris cornish there was no further
representation he had come to an end he
said that he had finished and i made a
note he had finished and obviously he's
just literally gone on for five minutes
to you summarizing the police's evidence
other people's evidence of a resident
trying to bring in other things and
quite frankly
it's unfair i i will go now to questions
but i'm just raising the point that this
officer has acted unfairly this morning
and we are prejudiced by that and i'm
going to have to deal with that later on
in my closing but we've got to be
we've got to we've got a statuary
process and procedure to be fair and i
didn't expect this morning to come up
and here again we've not heard um we've
i don't expect to hear from anyone else
now from environment health that's it um
is he calling any witnesses uh if he's
not calling any witnesses and he agreed
that he wouldn't but they would be there
for questions then i know what i'm doing
because i don't know how many other
people are going to speak for
environment
um
i think we did get to pay i checked this
this morning before the meeting with
officers and they said that the meeting
wasn't concluded totally so all right
i'll accept what you're saying mr
chairman yeah
and uh
and you're quite now that you can ask
questions
and uh you can ask the witnesses
questions okay so go ahead i'm most
grateful thank you sorry
mr cornelius wants to come back mr
cornish yeah i'll just go object to that
objection really i haven't discussed the
police's evidence in detail i referenced
something that uh superintendent mill
said in brief the rest of it is in my
evidence
okay
chairman mr chairman i think mr dance
has made a point well made um
he we're now in a situation of asking
questions um he he's made his
observations um if we could if you'd
like to move on to questions from
initially mr dads
yes please okay so so mr mr chairman for
you can i um just ask is
can i just ask les kin king quickly a
question um because he sets up the
equipment so mr king
yes hello hello um so good morning um i
understand that you set up the um
the monitoring equipment is that right
no
you don't no no i didn't set that out
that was seven chris cornish
okay and have you ever set the machines
out
uh for this case or for all new cases no
for this case uh not for this case no no
okay and in relation to
uh
being in
um the premises 20c or 18 have you been
in either of those premises yes i have
both you've been in both
okay
and uh in relation to councillor
uh cresswell
um or mr creswell um
he in evidence said that he's never had
an officer
into the uh into his premises
um
you may have heard that earlier on um in
relation to his premises have you made
any notes and have you served that as
evidence at all
i have um made notes um that has been
submitted in whether you've got a copy
or not i suspect not
okay so what what was that what what was
that those notes what what what what was
when would when did you go to that
premises to observe please
if you're happy then i'll then i'll read
it through no i just want to know when
you went there please i went there on
friday 24th of july 2020.
and
what time until when please i went there
at uh 8 10 p.m
and i left there at 1 15 pm not purely
in those premises but in the general
area of
the caffeine lounge
okay and you made your you made an uh
statement to in relation and kept your
notes for your visits yes yes it did i
keep poke a book okay and you've got the
agenda in front of you yes
no
all right have you seen the agenda for
today's hearing or the hearing
and i believe i have a copy um
in my emails but uh i haven't got it in
front of me now okay but your statement
doesn't appear in in your notes don't
appear in this um in in in this in this
pack no not to my knowledge no
um
the
one moment mr chairman
are you the officer
um that
that makes reference to
i'll just read it out it says
um noise levels increase after midnight
before midnight there were still
occasional shouts
raised voices that could clearly be all
ball through an open window
was in living room at times not a
nuisance
from there at that time
no they're not my nose no
no okay
one moment then please
hey
so on the um
on the 25th there's a note and i think
mr cornish has said that you you were
there it says at midnight there were
approximately six people outside
near caffeine lounge
inside a roped area
noise was good natured but likely to be
audible within nearby bedrooms is that
your comment
no but mine would be similar to that
not your comment no okay
um
well as i've not had any statements or
any information from you i i don't have
any further questions for you could i
just now miss jim and ask uh chris
cornis some questions please
ahead thank you um
mr cornish um i've got um
in evidence that there were three
times the equipment was
put into
um mr
uh doug
uh doug's uh premises dorington
um i've only got recordings of two has
there been two or three because there
seems to be an inconsistency
there's been three deployments the first
deployment was in january and it was
specifically in relation to a request to
prove that noise from a machine believed
to be a hand dryer and the audible base
beat
contrary to what we'd expect with the
sound insulation works this was related
to planning that was the primary reason
for putting the first out the second and
third deployments were due to the
ongoing complaints of that nature plus
an increase in suggestion of outdoor
noise from people so the first so the
first set of recordings have not been
made available to the committee
no because i don't relate to people
noise they relate to machinery noise and
base b and we discussed that with the
license holder on the premises on the
4th of february
thank you um in relation to
um
mr
hornish across creswell's premises uh
you've not
you've not provided any noise
observations from within that premises
have you
only a brief summary of observation we
were asked to answer some questions
while deploying equipment and observing
in the area it was known we were out
that night
so we entered the premises and had a
discussion about what was occurring
uh before we left to make other
observations around the premises um and
in the town
try if you can just try to be a bit more
specific for me officer it'll be very
helpful in relation to uh mr
crestwell um there hasn't been a there
hasn't been any uh monitoring inside
that premises has there no specific
targeted monitoring no
and and i've not received any specific
or targeted or any witness statement
specifically to do with
um
mr creswell i've got no evidence of any
monitoring or measurements in no um
20c is used because
all of what's being complained about
is occurring in that premises so the
internal noises for example when the
door banging isn't being experienced by
a 18 boring gate and others are down and
it's not going it's not going to affect
them in that same way so it this
to target our resources appropriately
there are often waiting lists for the
equipment
um it's it's best to target it to our
resource to the most appropriate place
the distance is involved so the free so
the three times you got the equipment
you deport it
each and every time in 20c and 1918
that's what i'm just establishing that
is correct yeah that's great thank you
uh and in relation to um
um
evidence of measure measured levels
in uh 18 there there is none
no there is done we could easily
calculate it but there is none yeah
right okay easy calculate well but not
no evidence right okay thank you um in
relation to um
um
independence do you
do you accept that you have to come
to this as being objective and and not
with a bias you you have to keep an open
mind
well i've been doing this for 20 years
and every case i've ever done has been
done without bias in a professional and
independent way
that's okay
uh and that you obviously you're aware
that mr mr cresswell
and um
the premises have have in effect uh had
some issues so for example mr creswell
threatened mr uh ward with a poll are
you aware that that of that um i wasn't
aware that uh there was any polls or
nature threat the license holder in
response to the first letter informed us
that uh mr cresswell had threatened them
and it was being uh looked at by the
police i responded to that at the time
by email
should i just let mr creswell come in
here mr creswell
thank you chair i totally object to what
mr dad said mr dad's words of using a
poll are totally incorrect
i will explain for two minutes what
happened that day
and it certainly didn't involve an
offensive weapon
a poll as you were saying mr chairman
i'm asking questions of mr corney she mr
cross will come back later yeah do you
want to come back do you want to come
back next i'll let you have a chance
after mr daddy
and completely untrue thank you all
right thank you
so um
mr cornish the um so
with ralph c in mind of the different
parties um have you
um have you taken that into account
whether to
to
test the feracity of his evidence
um given
i think you said earlier on we've
cooperated the truth of what we are
being told so in other words what you're
saying is you're relying on
police evidence to corroborate the truth
of what you're being told but i want to
know
what you've seen what have you
cooperated so in mr creswell you haven't
been into that and provided any evidence
have you
no but in every case um this is this is
how noise nuisance investigations are
done you are largely relying on the
person living in the property we can't
go and live in someone's property and
live it for them so we have to
corroborate what they're doing that is
done in various ways and
it's about plausibility so we have six
separate complainants six separate
households saying very similar things
which you would expect if that's if
that's occurring it's
i have been out and witnessed what's
happening on
friday the twenty-fourth into saturday
the 25th it corroborates exactly what
we've been told and what the police
officers told me when i asked for their
observations which i noted in the pack
um
it's simply establishing there is noise
occurring in that premises with people
socializing outside the back door yeah
and
that's all corroborates that now in many
cases we get told for example to put it
into a really simple turn a dog a dog is
barking all day every day if we go out
and the dog isn't barking it's not
barking all day every day we we then
have to drill down into that evidence
and find out what the fact of it is so
that is what what we're doing uh noise
nuisance recording equipment also is to
to back that up you won't be i mean we
put this stuff out all the time and many
times you get very little back compared
to what you've been told that then
doesn't corroborate the the resident's
evidence a dog barking how do we know a
recording of dog barking is from number
38 and not number 40. can we leave the
dog fighting
mr chairman i was asking questions
particularly about um how you cooperate
and obviously the officers going
obviously you you can listen to the
answers given and whether um they're
going off tangent but um
i've tried to interject can we go back
please in relation to recording um
we've heard from mr cresswell that he
provided you with recording sheets
you've not provided that evidence have
you
and not in this case at the moment
no okay
in relation to a graduated approach to
dealing with issues arising yep can you
tell me please or tell me in the pack
where is the letters
from january
february march april may june july
august
where that you um identify
with the premises
um
that there's been specific complaints
and uh asking them to come in and
address those complaints with you that
are pre the review application so
anything prior to august please
any letters
these specific emails weren't
put in as a large pack as if we're
taking a prosecution the discussion of
the case history is in the evidence um
and it's it was done your your client
has copies of those emails and a party
to those conversations
so in relation to a graduated approach
sitting down and developing an action
plan right okay so for example there was
the issue with the hand dryers that was
resolved
there's a noise limiting device
obviously you've not asked you didn't
write to readjust that in any way i
understand is that right
um i shouldn't have needed to i was told
in the fourth that it was only being
controlled by mr warden it will be left
there it was when we left the premises
okay in terms of action plans i mean
it's it's not for environmental
protection to go and sort it out for
them um they're aware of the issues they
have industry guidance and they're meant
to follow it
so you don't believe that you you should
do an action plan it's for them to to
deal with if if we have a good
relationship so following the fourth i
was hoping that was what we had achieved
there will be discussions we will get
asked i'm doing all i can is there
anything else i can do we weren't being
told that we've been told
no the allegations are false
so you agree there's no action plan
there was no dialogue to form an action
plan it was being denied by the uh
license holder
you can't make an action plan but
something the other party isn't
accepting
okay but
for example just just an example uh the
logs the logs from counselor cornish
that he completed sent to you which you
have not served
you could have summarized some of those
um
incidents or logs without identifying
the individual
and sent that to the premise and say
look we've got this issue from outside
for example people sitting on the wall
or someone in the smoking area and this
is incurred at this date and time did
you do that at all
okay so this this investigation has gone
on for since january so there may be
some confusion as to that the key
evidence for this review
and the reason for serving a notice was
what occurred in july all the
targeted monitoring was done from 20c as
representative of somewhere of the
nearest premises and also to capture the
door banging
the hand dryer was
slightly audible at the start of that
record and i understand further action
being taken since to replace the second
or third hand drive i'm not sure how
many there were
um
so
we target a representative location we
don't go to all six residents and
monitor all six we haven't got the
resources to do that and it wouldn't be
usual to do that in a case
uh this is a representative location the
noise will travel
based on the laws of physics
it's your neighbor to the left in your
neighbors the right or audible it's that
situation
so an appropriate investigation is done
that has found disturbing noises that
can be extrapolated to other premises it
reinforces what other premises are
saying not just mr cresswell the other
four residents
came here just a germ for one moment
because um sue carpenter's just had to
pop out for a couple of moments if we
just hold on for a moment please sorry
about that chris
stop being before no problem yeah mr
chairman
a four minute comfort break all right
can we have a five minute break sorry
about that everybody thank you five
minutes
okay thank you everybody we'll go back
to um
david dad's
mr cornish
um i asked you
that you've received logs
have you
written to the premises identifying some
of those matters identified in the logs
so that mr ward can look at those and
see whether there is any causal link to
his premises have you given the
opportunity by writing to him setting
out specific days and times when the
alleged nuisance has occurred i just
want to know yes or no whether there are
any letters you sent please
we sent letters not with specific logs
and dates well we have given dates
actually we reply to emails
it's not standard practice to share the
logs that are given by members of the
public to the the person alleged to be
making the be the perpetrator
well i'm i didn't ask whether you was
given the log so i wouldn't expect that
but for example have you got any letters
in your pack showing that you've written
some say on a friday night at a given
time say 1 30 there was a noise
disturbance um
and we like you to um
look at your your information or do you
have any comments have you any letters
like that to mr ward saying here's the
specific date and time of an alleged
matter arising um that we would like to
you to comment on have you done that at
all there has been an email with a
specific event yes
just one pack
but how many occasions time how many
times have you done that
with specific events it's been on two
occasions i believe
okay but the general nature complaints
just requires them to look at the door
and make sure it doesn't happen again
well as you say you're being objective
if you're being objective and you're not
there to see it
you obviously have to gather the
evidence from both parties don't you
yes
so um on two occasions and did they
respond on those two occasions to you
with any answers
um
initially they didn't find one of the
incidents being talked about um they're
probably looking on the wrong day
because of the transfer into the
following day when you go past midnight
um it was an altercation and the
response was well we stopped stopped a
crime and disorder issue so we ignored
the fact that there was noise generated
by it but they're they're in fact saying
it's not a causal link there's something
not to do with their premises
no no they they dealt with someone that
was um misbehaving and it caused caused
noise and argument in the precinct and
it's witnessed by members of the town
council community wardens
okay and when this was notified to the
applicant and when was and when was this
place this was in january in january
okay and
uh and the other occasion and
uh i believe uh a similar set of
incidents in march
uh there was specific questions about
auntie's house behavior really okay yes
but since
march there's been no other no other
letters of a similar kind like that
they were notified on the 4th of august
that we were investigating allegations
of regular disturbance by noise from
people
at the premises outside the premises as
well as other internal noises that were
alleged to be continuing yes in relation
to your own observations
so your personal observations
um can you tell me i've got um your
pages in front of me your logs
and i think they start at page 39
all the way through to um
page
48 is that right have you got the same
changes right yeah i've got printed off
so yeah i've got my i've got my
highlighter with me
can you just tell me please
which specific date or time
that you've been at the premises and
observed what this recording uh this
observation so in other words you're the
machine is recording and you're standing
there can you just give me um the date
and times when you were there please to
cooperate the recording yourself
personally there is no date and time
when we're exactly there ourself that's
why we use recording equipment for times
when we can't be there in person which
we don't have an out of hours service we
wasn't here on the night of the incident
so
so i'm absolutely clear i've just given
you an opportunity from page 39
all the way through page so i'm
absolutely clear so if we look at it
here's my question officer sorry i'm
just clarifying so it's absolutely clear
so 39 to page 48
i just i'm only talking about you at the
moment i can ask uh james a question but
you
your observations i want to know when
you were there whenever these recordings
uh any dates or times that you were
physically present so you can
corroborate what you heard on the
machine and what you saw uh police can
you be specific on dates and times
so page 41.
page 41. let me just go that yeah
recordings number two three four and
five are on the evening of the 24th into
the 25th
we left the actual front of the great
eastern road area at
15 minutes past the recording was made
the first recordings made nine minutes
after that while we was looking at other
premises in the town to see if they were
open
okay
the activities are consistent with the
noises that were recorded that we
witnessed as we left
okay so so as i understand it so the
recordings are um
24 39 45
and
208 you were not present we we're not
present
so that's my question so is there any
other time please officer
that you were present when there was a
recording being made when you were
personally present no that state it is
that's the purpose of the recording
equipment it's for when we're not
present okay thank you
um
and um can you clarify was there any
other officer present during those
recordings please
not during the recordings no it's a
two-man visit
okay thank you
now um when you installed the equipment
you said you spoke to counselor sorry mr
cresswell about it
um so he was aware of the recordings yes
that's correct we were asked to go and
visit him uh by mr thorin
yeah and mr dorington was obviously
aware of the installation of the
equipment yes he was operating the
equipment yes yeah okay
now in relation to um
um
the machinery i think i i've got you i
think i i got you quoted as saying
we
can pick up
audio queues yes so if i if i said to
all the counselors here now
i'm hoping they're in a room with a
window if something happened immediately
outside the window of their property
like it i'm sitting here now
we'd naturally
move our head to the window or whichever
direction it is to see we we've heard a
noise that's an audio cue yes
yeah that's an example of an audio q
there are many but yes yeah okay so that
as an example
on a machine
you can't get an audio cue from the
machine because it's just the speaker
you're just hearing the the the noise
you you can't get an audio cue from the
machine because you're not physically
there is that right
no that's not true
okay so for example if a car passes it
wasn't driving down the alleyway it was
on the road so we know where that is
we can tell distances we can tell echoes
we can tell muffling if it's around a
corner for example depending how far
around the corner the path of travel of
noise
so
well
you you can also it's important to know
this summary
is is
the actual recordings
the resident is telling us
that's what i heard the resident is
controlling that recording telling us
telling us when they've pressed the
button and why they've pressed the
button yeah so
they are telling us where it is as well
yes so just doing that
so um
i will come back to the motor vehicle
example you gave in a minute but not to
lose the thread pressing the button can
you tell me please from page as i say 39
um all the way through
um can you tell me the times when the
because normally i would see a where the
buttons been activated so can you tell
me which ones are the ones that where
it's been activated
that's how the machine works it works by
someone pressing a button the machine
then recalls we've set it up to recall
one minute before that has two purposes
to catch instantaneous noises that might
have made someone wake up
and then they've got to find the buttons
there they're waking from sleep
and and
but this is recording all the time isn't
it no it's it's taking noise data
numbers sound pressure in the air
the recording the audio recordings we
can't sit that was that machine was out
for nearly 12 days 11 in a bit days we
can't sit there and listen to um
that many days before recording that's
many hours um
it's a snapshot so for example
the resident would say i was disturbed
between midnight and four in the morning
and here's some examples and i'll press
the button at this time because
yes
okay so there are times that there was
noise they are snippets of noise
disturbances being described yes but not
each one of these is triggered by a
button is it yes it is yes oh you're
saying it's triggered by abs absolutely
yeah and it is set up to record five
minutes with a one minute pre-trigger it
also catches people trying to catch
people out
as well so you know you might get a
resident that's playing his own music in
the house and you can tell that the
clarity of the the uh
recording can often tell you that
actually that's coming from the same
room not through a party wall for
example so so for example if a resident
say that's got a grudge
um
or a bias
could so you say about catching them out
could potentially manipulate this
machine and by creating a noise which is
recorded is that
right uh yeah it could do i mean i'm not
sure that someone would be able to get
20 people to come and stand out their
window for four hours but yeah
well no i just asked to answer the
question officer not to give an example
four hours 20 people no one suggests
that anywhere
is there anywhere that someone's sitting
out for four hours
20 people on this machine because i i
don't think the machine counts how many
people are out there do that do they no
it doesn't but um
i'm asking you to be objective if i can
because i want you to as a professional
officer just be objective so i'm saying
yeah there is a a possibility that
someone could go down the alleyway shout
but that but they know the machine is
there recording so it could have it
could be manipulated yeah and if we had
one or two occasions in in a night or in
the week uh that would certainly be
something that we would have to consider
in this case i think the
evidence is uh implausible that
someone's recreated all of that over
three hours and 30 odd minutes um of
recordings that depends on motive but
it's not it's not impossible is it
it's highly improbable given what's
being recorded it's highly improbable it
also corroborates that there are groups
of people you can clearly tell there's
groups of people in close proximity to
the microphone you know you say we can't
tell you know we we know our loud people
talk roughly
and we know how noise behaves over
distances
square law physics right so in relation
to your own observations of the premises
um
so now moving on
for a moment
your
observations um can you tell me
um
the
the actual um
noise measurements that you've taken
when you've been there in person
have you got any evidence for that where
would i find that well firstly
noise noise numbers aren't the main
drive of what determines a nuisance from
this type of activity is the nature and
the noise is it likely to wake someone
up
so no i haven't been there and noise
server that's why we use the remote
noise nuisance recording equipment is
deployed all around the country
because the councils don't have our
services now i think we're down to less
than 100 nationwide now how many times
have you been um on a friday on saturday
night
um to
make a personal observation
uh once on the friday the 24th into the
saturday the 25th
all right
[Music]
and
in the in the evidence there's a summary
of mine and les kings
observations
obviously
that's what i read out wasn't that
wasn't it yeah yeah and i think that's
where i i thought it was less king we
had a conversation with that
evidence is summarized in that it says
the environmental protection officers is
a summary not a verbatim
contemporaneous note so you've done one
and liz king um how many times has he
been just once at the same time as you
yeah correct yeah we don't have an out
of hour service so
okay 11 o'clock till 4 in the morning
isn't a shift that we ran okay and james
uh buckingham um has um and has he been
there
or
only during the day yeah
one moment please mr chairman
could you just i can i just um ask my
client if there's any other questions i
think i've done all the questions i need
but i just need to ask my client is that
all right
yes of course thank you
okay
uh mr chairman
uh i just one final question uh
mr cornish this
that you you've
this is in your entire evidence you've
not put any other statements in from any
other residents any logs any witness
statements or anything like that this
what we've got here is your evidence
that's yeah that's that's our reason for
making representation yes yes and uh
mr chairman i have no further questions
all right
thank you mr that's right uh we'll move
on to other questions uh the applicant
uh trevor cresswell would you like to
ask any questions of the environmental
officer
uh not the environmental officer um
what i would say was i i would at some
point like to respond to what mr dad
said
well you could do that in your closing
statement
actually i can do um but i
would like to say it now because i feel
what he said i don't think it's a pro
it's not appropriate at the moment it's
questions for the for the environmental
office i'm afraid
okay but i don't think what he said was
appropriate even
but you could put that straight in your
closing statement okay
okay
all right thank you um it's the
constabulary um got any questions for
the environmental protection
yes we do
[Music]
got my questions
right in the view of environmental
health is the evidence you've provided
consistent with the caffeine lounge
primarily operating as an e-gaming
lounge or as a late-night bar
no it is not especially after the 4th of
july
not
what
is it sorry it's not what i would expect
from a gaming lounge with people gaming
and having some drinks on the side no no
so you're saying it's more late night
bar
correct yeah yeah
uh in the view of environmental health
is the evidence you provided consistent
with that provided by police and
residents that have shown that the
caffeine lounge is attracting
intoxicated persons crime disorder noise
and anti-social behavior after 2 300
hours
that is correct and if you read all the
summary of evidence you can see some of
the stuff that's being said
clearly audible on a microphone within
someone's premises
um and
they're even making statements like it's
hot in there don't run to the smoking
area i mean there's no other
place open with a smoking area or that
might get hot
right
and in the view of environmental health
with the cessation of licensable
activities at 2300 hours provide a
remedy to the problems that have been
described at this hearing
and in particular to the distress caused
to local residents by noise and
antisocial behavior after 2 300 hours
we believe it will it'll be more like
what was described where you might have
a couple of smokers in between their
games
right
and finally um to the environment
knowledge of environmental health were
there any similar complaints by local
residents of noise and antisocial
behavior before the caffeine lounge
commenced operation in december 2019
none at all in in the time that i've
been at the authority and i believe in
the in here before since eastern's
closed was the last time we had um
complaints of this nature in that area
there was nothing raised at the asb
panel meetings previously either placed
up bellevue park for example have come
up uh in the past as hotspot areas where
you might get any social behavior in the
street or public spaces that great
eastern road area has not come up on
that panel
all right okay now that that's it from
the police thank you
okay thank you shannon uh planning
enforcement officer have you got any
questions
uh thank you chair no questions from me
thank you
okay thank you and uh mr dorington i
don't believe he's here
no
no okay
at the moment
okay thank you right um the committee
now would you like could i ask you a
question no no not at the moment trevor
sorry you've missed missed your bit
um peter beer would you like to ask any
questions
um
thank you mr chairman um yes just to mr
chris cornish just some points of
clarification because i've made notes
and i've gone through the pack um you
said at one point and forgive me if i've
got the words a little bit wrong
town council wardens were in attendance
um
is this
during the day or what's this at night
because i'm under the impression that
the town cancer wardens are going to be
finished by six or seven o'clock at
night but uh you you you did make that
comment
that's a very good point um councillor
beer and the wardens were in the
precinct and along with the high street
taking christmas decorations down after
midnight i believe it was the early
hours of the fourth of january
oh so this is right yep that's varian
and observed to observe the incident yep
yep thank you that that makes sense uh
the other point i've got about four no
clarification
uh something was said about logs
um and i put a question mark i wasn't
quite sure what was meant although i
heard some other comments later on
uh was that referring to members of the
public
or what yes we ask in all all cases of
noise alligator or any nuisance
allegation whatever the topic may be for
them to complete a record um of when
they're disturbed
when they feel they're unreasonably
disturbed should i say but we don't want
to know when they
notice
a noise or smoke for example
so we need to get a view on how how
regularly something's occurring how long
it's going on for the times of day for
example that we can then go and
corroborate um
what it is and it also forms a picture
of nuisance and nuisance isn't just
about how loud something is is a it's a
consideration of
how loud the time of day the character
and nature of the noise the duration it
goes on for how frequently it recurs for
example
and a couple of more um the
also you said something about reporting
sheets or it might have been something
that
mr dad's put to you about reporting
sheets and uh i think i took something
here no reporting sheets what was that
in reference to or or what does that
mean what are reporting sheets
our log sheets are described by many
different people in different ways i
think mr des was referring to the record
diary record sheets is what i i call
them um but they're called nuisance logs
records uh and all sorts of things
really right and my last one
is um
uh something less king i've got here uh
notes not in the pack
somebody referred to that which um
i think was mr um
dad's um i could be wrong there but i
think it was him
and said that but
then later on you've said
somebody you read out part of
a statement that is in this package
which you then said was um
mr
les king's comments is that correct um
there was a lot of question saying that
these notes weren't in there and now
you've said that something was read out
and you've said that this was les king's
comments well on page five there is a
description of what environmental
protection officers witnessed that was
uh what i and les king witnessed that's
um
taken from
our joint observations really they're
not the specific individual witness
statement of each officer because there
will be some differences for example mr
king went to
the back of the premises and walked down
the alleyway while i stayed at the
roundabout observing activities there
so
what was read out and not the notes that
were not in the pack
that's what i can't understand there was
a statement made that the notes were not
in the pack and yet you've said that
this is what les king and you read it
out
yeah there's a four five four yeah four
paragraphs that i've put is a summary of
our visit so the the verbatim each
separate person observations weren't put
in there as separate individuals it was
a summary the the understanding i've
been given in previous um training and
experience this is this is an open
discussion um and when we're not
normally required to put in a 200 nod
page
um case file with every shred of uh
emails letters record sheets um this is
a license here and not a court of law
yeah
thank you very much mr corn that's very
helpful
okay peter thank you um sue um
thank you chair um if you could just
help me um with reminders or
clarification
um
what would you regard just you sort of
touched on this just now um as
unreasonable disturbances to residents
from noise this refers to the third
paragraph on page 33 of our pack
yes um unreasonable disturbance noise is
anything that would materially interfere
with someone's normal use of their
property so in this particular case it
is all about what would wake the average
person up
okay thank you
um when when all of this was coming
forward uh either
planning or licensing um were there any
conditions that that um you proposed any
particular concerns that you raised
yeah i raised these the potential
concerns there were four points of
concern are raised but noise from people
outside smoking was one of them and
noise from access and egress was another
at both both committees
condition
specifically right into people noise on
the planning application was not to use
their doors into the precinct after 11
o'clock at night to allow people in um
we felt that would stop a passer buyers
coming in
through the roller shutter doors for
example and also stop people accessing
egressing that way into an echoey
precinct that's surrounded by by
residents it would then take it more on
the street and more manageable in in the
way they were describing the premises
used in addition the noise management
policy was also required by planning and
by condition on the license there are
also one two three four five six six
conditions on the premises license that
are involved with monitoring taking
action uh over dispersal noise and
people noise outside
and remedy in that really
so regular checks on outside areas is a
condition that the
license holder applied themself at the
license hearing it says the premises
license holder shall ensure that a
member of staff regularly checks on
outside areas where patrons are
observing the smoke free legislation in
the designated smoking areas
for example there's another one about
monitoring inside and out
whether activities will have excessive
noise at neighbouring properties and
take appropriate remedial steps
all right thank you is that obviously
that not our
planning isn't isn't uh something we
need to look at it it's the licensing
aspect thank you for that
um you um we've talked a certain amount
about what has been done over time
um concerns about noise obviously date
back to the beginning of the year and we
know that corridors interrupted that
um could you just summarize for me very
briefly uh any steps that you have taken
to address the noise concerns anything
written anything verbal i know you've
you've talked about some of them but if
you could just give me a brief summary
um
unfortunately there's been extensive um
correspondence with the license holder
because of the the overlap we're
planning as well as as this which
complicated
a lot of the complaints for example the
internal noise the sound insulation
issues and the door issues which were to
be agreed prior to them opening um would
resolve that um and certainly as of as
of may the
incidents in the first recording summary
that are presented
um there's much less people noise there
is a particularly bad night um that was
something that would have needed further
investigation but obviously kobe had
stopped that and the state of affairs
changed after that but we have held
meetings um james buckingham's held
online
meetings like we're doing now
with the license holder there's been
emails it's the response and the
engagement from the license holder
that's really stopped that um entering a
meaningful stage like mr dad suggested
with an action plan um there wasn't an
acceptance of there being a problem to
have that conversation
at any point
okay
um
you you also i think mentioned when you
were speaking earlier that um
an observation about what might be
comparable complaints elsewhere in the
town
um could could you just clarify that
again that you you're saying that that
sort of after 2300 there are no
comparable complaints elsewhere or maybe
there are
there was there was two uh following the
lockdown easing in on the fourth of july
i mean
we get approximately 50 complaints a
year about um
licensed premises across the two
districts normally
um so this isn't a new thing for us um
in specifics there were two premises
that where residents were reporting
noise in the street and noise due to
smoking outside
after 11 o'clock i believe those
premises shut up midnight
um
both uh one one of them she was quite
draconian um was was a zero tolerance
policy even went and advertised it in
the press
um he's going to ban people limit a
number of smokers have dormant on and he
was going to stop having entry after 11
o'clock at night no new entry to
discourage people from coming along from
where they've just left a lot of places
were closed at 11 there was a couple
open until midnight i believe all right
thank you um the the last thing i would
ask and i might need advice here from
our legal advisor if i can ask it
about the noise abatement issue have
there been any developments or progress
since then and i don't know um david
smith if you i i think to
um answer it as simply as possible an
appeal has been submitted and it's yet
to be determined i think absolutely
thank you i can give you thank you
thank you those are my questions thank
you
david price have you got any points of
clarification
do i have none but do you have any
questions chairs you're missing yourself
out
yeah
not at the moment i've been uh
people have been asking my questions and
i've been listening
so no not at the moment so i think
before we go to the planning
enforcement's um
presentation we'll have a 15-minute
break for coffee that's okay with
everybody
okay thank you
so we'll meet back at 11 15.
okay
welcome back everybody uh now we'll go
to the representation from the planning
enforcement
yep sorry uh it's james buckingham from
environmental health we had the
discussion earlier that i was going to
be allowed to speak on behalf of the
environmental protection team
i'll only is only a two minute uh
summary representation but that was what
was agreed
no absolutely not
well you object to that mistake you've
already objected mister
you've already objected mr dads and it's
already been
just well agreed upon by and advised by
the legal advisor so again i'd defer to
the legal adviser on this
david legal
what points are we are these points in
clarification mr buckingham
yeah it might help the committee they
are um certainly amplification of the
representation we've submitted they um
are not uh issues that have um
i won't say they haven't been raised by
mr
cornish
but they
are
two issues that need to be discussed
and provide much greater clarification
i'm not saying that they don't overlap
with something that mr cornish may have
said in passing but they are separate
issues um that he has raised yes
i can tell you what the two issues are
if you would like
mr chairman i'd like to raise an
objection and if i could make a legal
submission
okay yeah
well firstly um
the
the representation that we've heard from
environment office there is in the pack
it's not by could you put it on polls
please whoever that is
the in relation to um
the environmental health we have the
representation in the pack
um and
therefore
um we've heard from the representative
the lead i was told from the outset from
day one of this hearing that um
chris cornish would be um speaking and
he would be relying on two witnesses
um les and james uh and
there is only um you you can't have two
rep it's like having two separate
representations from different police
officers and in a day the environmental
health should have called all their
witnesses all those that wish to speak
once that's closed we go to questions
because i've just now done all my
questions and clarification and we're
now moving on to planning and it's
completely inappropriate i've not got um
there's no proper structure here the
environmental health
responsible authority have made their
reps that's it if there's now going to
be another report
it's completely inappropriate
chair
from day one of this hearing we have
said that this is a joint representation
and therefore it's not it's not uh
incumbent or mr um
cornish to
say everything that there is for
environmental protection if we as a
responsible assault authority wish to
divide up our representation between two
different speakers and that is what he's
been doing what we tend to do with
dividing our representation up then that
we are perfectly entitled to do it i
have done that on a number of hearings
in the past
yeah as a witness and and let me finish
that is what has been stated from day
one that is what's already you've heard
from mr price to say that that i am
allowed to do that and you've heard mr
smith say there was nothing that
precludes it now mr dads may well
um
try to convince you that that is not
acceptable but i'm sorry it's not in the
rules there's nothing in the rules to
say that we cannot divide up our
representation between two officers
nothing whatsoever now show me where it
is mr dads please
well the under the show me where it is
mr dan yes i'm answering it
let him speak please yeah rather than
being confrontational
with the chairman that the
the process is that a representation is
made within 28 days that has been made
and we've got it there
the speakers as indicated at the
beginning would be chris cornish you
told me to go and have a conversation i
did
we clarified at that point he would be
speaking and james and liz would be
available as witnesses to answer
questions chris corners just called his
evidence and you've asked him to give
that he could have caused james as a
witness to add
or or to speak to the representations
made they have not all i'm saying is
that because i've never asked my
questions they could be trying to undo
what
what i've said uh or the case plan i'm i
prepare my case i prepare uh what i'm
going to be doing it's completely
inappropriate to keep on splitting it
off i'm entitled to know what procedure
is being followed
okay let me just speak to uh
david legal what do you think i know
i'll get sue and peter's opinion as well
what
mike's not on david
i i'm concerned in the regard and it's
only with regards to the fact that
there are two points that i think mr
buckingham is saying he wants to clarify
or feels would be of assistance to the
committee to clarify
i i am only concerned that
we need to stick
to the representations that are being
made and amplification
i i am concerned that there has been
some moving away from that um we've come
back on track
um
i hear what mr dads has to say
um and i hear what mr buckingham has to
say um
whilst on the one hand there has to be
some
some structure as mr dad says so far as
the representations are being made
um i'm just concerned as to why these
representations were not
perhaps alluded to when mr cornish gave
his representations earlier
is there any reason why that
didn't happen it's not a criticism i
just want to get some clarity mr
buckingham can you assist
well i think it's probably the way that
this committee has been um
dominated i'd say it by mr dad mr dad's
told the committee what the procedure
was it wasn't the other way around and
that was from day one and that's sorry
i've had conversations with some of the
other responsible authorities
about this um the police actually had to
raise it at the end of their
representation that what mr dads was
telling the committee was actually
incorrect about the rules governing uh
licensing hearings
what role did i get wrong sorry i'm
speaking mr dads can you not interrupt
me thank you one thing i've got to say
i've got hold on mr dads i've got to
disagree that mr dads has been running
the meeting we've been running the meet
you've come in after we've done all the
questions and then you want to say a few
things
you know
it's clearly in our representation we
are we are listed as three um
parties to the representation myself mr
cornish mr king
we are three we are represented uh we've
i'm a bit confused as to why we're
actually having this discussion because
you know we had it at the very start of
this meeting about half past nine and at
that point you've come back with this
after we've done the after we've all
done the questions and then we're just
about to go to planning and now you want
to go back
sorry i i don't want to be
confrontational but my understanding and
we can rerun that it's on video we can
rerun it but at that point i thought mr
smither had gave his guidance that i
would be allowed to speak now because
that guidance was given mr cornish has
not given some of his the evidence
we prepared our case we
we prepared what we were going to do
prior to this meeting today and we
agreed mr cornish would deliver certain
things if i was to be allowed to speak
mr cornish would not would not deliver
certain other things and i would say
them now
so that's why
at the start of this meeting this
morning we clarified who would be
allowed to speak and who wouldn't and we
were told that i would be allowed to
speak and therefore mr cl mr cornish has
not given some of the evidence that this
this responsible authority wishes to
give
okay what i'm going to do is
ask peter and then see what they think
and then go back to legal peter beer
what do you think your committee member
uh thank you mr chairman um well first
of all
uh i don't consider that mr
um dads has been running this meeting uh
i think mr chairman it's a difficult
meeting and i think you're certainly
running it um
i am concerned that this has come in at
this stage uh and i'm just wearing
perhaps a planning hat here um i did ask
questions to mr cornish uh relating to
mr les king
because he had brought this up in his um
uh
comments and he answered them um there
wasn't anything that i'd got
regarding mr buckingham um and had i had
a question or something that came up i
think i would have put that question
also to mr cornish um i i think at this
stage
um
we've got to the end of the
environmental um
people's submission and uh i feel that
um
[Music]
great respect to mr buckingham it should
have been included it should have been
in the packs and things like that um and
we we are where we are and i think we
should move on to the next part which i
think is the plan and enforcement thank
you mr beer um sue comptail what do you
think do you agree with mr beer um
i i am concerned about the um procedures
that um it does seem that we'd be going
back on onto environment i mean i i i'm
interested in what um james buckingham
might have to say
um except that if it were to be new
evidence
none of the other parties
would have had an opportunity to
consider it and formulate our questions
if it were not new evidence and it was
simply amplification of what we have in
our pack
then then i would i would not be as
concerned if however it is an
amplification of what we have in our
pack
maybe that could be put into
the closing submissions um
you know that everything we're looking
at is not just what what we hear and see
in our meetings it's all of the the
massive amount of evidence that we have
it in our packs so
um i i think it might
adversely prejudice um the license
holders case
if we open up new evidence that they
haven't had an opportunity to see
so um
much as i would like to hear from mr
buckingham
my concerns are about procedure
thank you
hold on hold on one moment and i did
stop mr creswell coming back after he'd
had his chance to speak so um i'll let
you do mr buckham say speak well as as i
said um
i i thought that i'd been
um
granted the opportunity to speak after
mr cornish had i not had been granted
that opportunity then we had agreed
myself mr cornish that he would give
that evidence
that additional clarification it's not
new evidence it's clarification of
what's in our existing sorry what i
intend to would like to say is not new
evidence
nobody's going to be caught out it's uh
amplification of what's in our
the environment protection team's
representation
i'm perfectly happy to
if there is an opportunity at the end of
the hearing i'm perfectly happy to say
what i need to say at that point um if
i'm given that opportunity that is okay
thank you okay uh
david i think from what the uh cancers
have said i think we're gonna move on to
planning
uh is that agreeable with you and i
don't think there is an opportunity for
the environmental to speak later in the
meeting
mr chairman on a point of clarification
and order that was that my point i was
just gonna push to you before we move on
that i don't think uh with what we've
got in front of us there is that
opportunity for mr buckingham to um come
back in but i think um
uh i assume that they're all going to
have their summon up so
perhaps mr cornish can work it in there
i don't know
they're not doing the summoning up it's
only the um the applicant the license
see and
okay
all right well i'm gonna sorry sorry mr
buckingham what i would say then is some
of our the as a responsible authority
you are not going to get to hear some of
our representation
i would like that noted
well i wish you'd come in before before
we already
i thought i had come in at the start of
this morning's meeting when i from my
understanding
clear guidance was given by mr price and
mr smith that i would be allowed to
speak after mr cornish that's that's
that's what i heard if if everybody uh
everybody else in this virtual room
heard something different then you know
well okay i admit i'm wrong oh we should
well we should come in before we went
through the questions and moved on sorry
right we're going to move on to um
planning enforcement
sorry to interrupt you i think emily
you'll have a hand up
emily thank you karen and thank you
chairman if i can just intervene here um
i don't think you've had the final say
from the legal advisor
and i would just remind you that you are
in public session i wonder whether it
would be sensible to have a very short
adjournment to agree with all parties
how you're going to handle this and then
come back with your determination
because ultimately it is yours chair
your decision to decide whether you take
this additional speaker or not
so can i have an adjournment with the
offices is that right
uh david smith do we have is we don't
have a private session that we can go
back to i don't know whether that's
right karen do we need a an invite
i have set up a private session meeting
for you to um go into should you need to
was that today or have i missed it
yeah just recently okay
could i just have an opportunity because
i i haven't had an opportunity to
comment on what's been said before you
retire
yeah of course yeah
just shortly
it is it is about fairness and a proper
procedure i i think this hearing's gone
we're into a third day i know i've taken
my fair share of the time but but the
environment to health did have um plenty
of opportunity to
contribute call witnesses
and and i don't think there is any
prejudice there's prejudice now because
if you go back which you're entitled to
do if you want to
you'll will have to go back through
answering all questions again and
obviously i may then be prejudiced on
how we're going forward because
obviously i asked all my points of
clarification and preparing my case i
just think the um at the outset i spoke
to mr cornish and i was told that les
king
and james are witnesses and that's why i
raised the original issue about where's
their statement what are they going to
say that's what was my understanding his
name is not on the representation it's
not been signed
so it's all
um it's all a bit um unusual i would
expect to see
the name on the representation
understand who's calling the evidence
who are the witnesses and i clarified
that from the very start of the hearing
i was told that chris cornish was going
to be the lead and he would call the
witnesses or have the witnesses
available for questioning and if that is
changing
i think that would be unfair now at this
stage of the process
okay
so um
yes
mr cornish has his hand raised chair i
don't know if he wishes to help us
mr cornish do you have a
comment
yes chad just very brief um
a
form was submitted on the 25th of
september
stating that les king and um james
buckingham would want to speak uh i did
have the agreement i understand mr dads
didn't wasn't aware of that and that's
why i for expedience i agreed
um
that we will skip that part
um mr buckingham
is going to be
talking about stuff that touches upon
things that mr dad has raised both in
his own speech
and uh questioning of the other parties
of this process so there's stuff that we
didn't know was going to be brought up
so for example we're now hearing about
dorman and limiting smokers and and
things like that so i just wanted to
clarify that really
all right well we're going to a 10
minute recess with legal and uh the
councillors is that agreed everyone so
we're back at quarter to 12.
no that's more yeah quarter 12 yeah
right
hello everybody are we all we're all
here i hope um
i've decided to um let mr buckingham
uh say his
two points for clarification
as
we feel like he missed out on the end of
the environmental presentation
um as long as he sticks to the two
points for clarification
um i've listened to the concerns of mr
dads but this is my decision
we'll you will all be able to ask
questions if you need to
so if mr buckingham would like to say
his two points for clarification please
thank you chairman
um
[Music]
just a as a background i'm
a chartered environmental health officer
and i've worked in the environmental
protection team for baby district
council for 24 years
and i've managed that team for the last
14 years
my first point i think we we need to
address the elephant in this virtual
room
and that is precisely what is this
premises
both the premises license and the
planning app planning permission
state that it's supposed to be primarily
an e-gaming center
an esports lounge
the application for a license signed by
mr ward on the in november 1980
1919 sorry 2018
stated opening times will vary according
to occasionally hosting international
competitions in different time zones
the atmosphere we want is that of a fun
and relaxing place for customers to hang
out on the sofas or chairs and tables
and enjoy a new licensing experience
the condition conditions of the premises
license are also explicit on this matter
condition 3.2 the primary business of
the premises is an e-gaming center or
e-sports lounge
condition 3.4 the premises shall not be
used as a vertical drinking
establishment
i'd like to remind the committee that
these conditions were imposed following
a hearing by the licensing subcommittee
into the original application
so careful thought was therefore clearly
given to the problems that the premises
could cause if such conditions
restricting the use of the premises were
not imposed
the planning committee which uh council
beer i believe chaired
also specifically asked mr dads and i
quote would anybody be able to come and
use the lounge what steps would you take
to prevent people who just want to come
and have a drink if they're not actual
gamers to come along when the pubs are
shut
mr dads replied and i quote
the primary business is gaming if
someone wants to come in only for a
drink that's not the custom week that's
not the custom we want
we won't encourage it we won't give
service
this will be for e-gaming
we are not a late-night bar and we've
said in the license there's no vertical
drinking so you can just you can't just
come in and just be vertical drinking
mr dads was later asked
what would you do to prevent people that
have just come to drink and mr dads
replied
refuse service
the licensing committee and the planning
committee clearly placed a significant
amount of trust in mr ward to operate
the establishment as it was originally
applied for and to abide by the
conditions that is imposed on the
premises
license
what is patently obvious is that the
primary business is not e-gaming
the committee are all very sensible
people and you would have heard the
testimony of the residents environmental
protection officers and the police
mr dads dismisses all the evidence
you've heard as just two residents or
the alleged bias of my colleague mr
cornish this is of course complete
nonsense and i'm sure no one is really
that gullible as to believe it
the truth is that all of the flats of
the precincts have complained to the
council about noise and disturbance
members i believe have had a map showing
this
all decisions taken during the council's
investigations of the noise complaints
will be taken by me and mr cornish often
in consultation with other experienced
environmental health officers there is
no bias whatsoever
and on the subject of bias i mean
my sort of rhetorical question for the
committee there's been a lot of
discussion about what the noise read
noise
recordings
um
what you can hear what you can't hear
where the noise might come from i mean
it's my understanding that six
uh noise recordings were actually
submitted to the to the committee um and
i'm not i don't intend to play them um
we've been here for three days that's
long enough but um i would ask an
assurance that you just all go away
before your decision
and listen to those recordings
lis is that a reasonable level of noise
um i know what i think uh but please i
would ask you to do that
okay
residents of two of those flats have
given very compelling evidence about how
the noise and anti-social behavior of
the premises has impacted on their lives
members the primary use of this premises
is a bar it's not an e it's not e-gaming
and if you remember one thing from these
three days then it should be the poor
people who used to live above a shot
that sold buckets and mobs and had a
quiet life
overnight their lives were turned to
misery by the active activities of this
so-called e-gaming lounge
wherever the premises has been able to
whenever the premises have been able to
operate without coverage restrictions
the residents have not had an unbroken
night sleep and it's caused them severe
stress
mr dads would have you believe that this
is all caused by people who have nothing
to do with the caffeine lounge that just
passes by from other premises
but members you've heard the sound
recordings or at least hope you have
that were made by mr dorrington night
after night during january to march and
again during the summer when the
business was operating without covered
restrictions
you don't need to be an expert or to
have special equipment to know that the
people making the noise in those
recordings were right under mr
dorington's bedroom window on the rear
forecourt of the caffeine lounge
and most of the noise isn't from
occasional rowdy behaviour or fights
it's constant on and off all night long
from patrons simply talking often
animatedly until 2 or 3 30 in the
morning
as i said i've worked for baber for 24
years and i can assure the committee
that we have never received complaints
about rowdy people in the street at this
location before the caffeine lounge
opened
members the primary use of this premises
is a bar it is not e-gaming
the residents have no vendetta against
mr ward they had a quiet life until this
premises opened
i'm sure they'd have no objection to a
proper e-gaming lounge where people
played computer games and what was it
hang out on sofas and chairs i think it
was described in the application
no what is
what this is uh what's been performed
here is a charade plain and simple
remember what the application was for an
e-gaming lounge with opening times
varying according to occasionally
hosting international competitions in
different time zones
that word occasionally central to this
whole hearing
i looked up the definition in the
dictionary and it states occurring or
done infrequently
and irregularly
not every night
this isn't arguing about the meaning of
words it's critical to the cred
credibility of the whole licensing
process
the original licensing committee
residents members of the public and
responsible authorities were all told
that the primary use of the premises
would be e-gaming and that it would only
need to open on an occasional basis to
host international tournaments
members this is a bar that opens until
the early hours of the morning every
night of the week whenever it is able to
do so when there are no covered
restrictions
no one is disputing that e-gaming takes
place but to say that this is the
primary use doesn't bear scrutiny when
you've heard the evidence of crowds of
drinkers at the bar and outside
in my day it would have been darts or a
pool table at the corner of a pub
now it's a few people playing games on
on consoles whilst the rest of the
clientele are engaged in the true
business of the caffeine lounge which is
selling and consuming alcohol
and if you choose not to believe me then
consider the statements of the police
who've had to dedicate a huge amount of
resource to policing the premises i
think they said 22 visits in a year
premises is a magnet for drinkers when
all the other pubs in sudbury are closed
you've heard evidence from pc butters
and superintendent mills about what goes
on inside the premises who's gaming and
who um and i think superintendent mills
witnessed crops of drinkers outside the
premises
because he felt he had to visit himself
to witness how the premises is actually
being operated
quite simply
the licensing system here is being
undermined a bar selling alcohol until
three am is not what was applied for
if this is allowed to continue what is
to stop any other pub in sudbury great
coal at cornard or capelson mary putting
in a few game consoles and applying to
sell alcohol until three in the morning
if the caffeine lounge is allowed to
continue to sell alcohol and open until
3 30 in the morning every night of the
week then the good people and residents
of sudbury who would expect the
licensing committee to uphold the
licensing objectives on their behalf
will have been lied to
no one wants to stop the business they
just want it to be what it is supposed
to be according to its premises license
an e-gaming
lounge the original licensing and
planning committees placed their trust
in mr ward to operate principally as an
e-gaming lounge and open until early
morning on only an occasional basis
they took mr ward at his word
that trust has clearly been abused from
the first day the premises opened
mr ward has offered to provide door
staff for two nights of the week as a
magic cure to all of the problems that
have been caused by the business
but what about the other five nights of
the week
environmental protection the police
received reports of noise and
anti-social behavior on every night of
the week not just fridays and saturdays
the location of what is clearly a late
night bar is simply incompatible with
having several facts flats located
immediately above it
the residents of those flats will get no
respite so long as the primary business
of the caffeine lounge is allowed to be
in reality a late night bar
i would respectively submit the
committee should curtail the operating
hours of the business to around 11 pm
which is when the majority of the
residents just like you or i would
expect to be able to sleep without being
disturbed
disturbed mr ward will be free to apply
for temporary event notices to host
occasionally internationally gaming
tournaments in the early hours of the
morning when they need to align with
other time zones
and finally the committee could also
hold mr water his promise to run the
premises primarily as an e-gaming
business
by imposing a condition stipulating that
alcohol will only be supplied to
customers who have booked in to play
e-games
this is a common license condition are
other true e-gaming venues
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak
all right thank you mr buckingham
right um
david dads would you like to
ask some questions
yeah before i start mr i didn't
interrupt i think that's a complete
abuse of process it wasn't just two
points it was a complete new
resubmission there were matters raised
in there that was not in the evidence
there's no witness statement and i will
just make it note now that i think that
that was a complete abuse of the process
but i will treat it as i would treat any
other representation and now
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to ask questions
okay thank you
mr buckingham
you're the manager of the department are
you
i'm the environment assistant manager
yes
assistant manager who's the manager
john grayling
right um you um
you've not um provided a written
statement of truth
and a written statement have you in this
case a witness statement
a witness statement or or statement of
truth
regarding uh we've
the representation that's before you in
the agenda pack
okay and in relation to um
your
personal knowledge of these premises
we were told earlier on by your
colleague you've not attended in the
evening is that right
uh not in an official capacity but i
live in near sudbury and i have gone
past it on a multitude of occasions so i
have a quite detailed knowledge actually
in my own personal life yes but you're
giving evidence today i appreciate that
yeah all right i'm just clarifying
you've not made a a representation in
your personal capacity have you
no
no so in relation as an officer of the
council on duty um you have not been um
to this um premises have you in the
evening
uh not during the evening no no
and uh even um uh if you believed a
member of the public had concerns about
the premises what they saw that they
would report that and hopefully you
would then go and make some observations
yourself formally as a officer for the
council yes
not necessarily that's why i manage a
team i have a team of officers and
obviously have to allocate those
resource and instruct officers to go and
visit and make notes in my place i can't
do everything
of course
during the period of january
to august when the application was made
we've heard from mr cornish there's only
been one one observation by officers in
july that's right isn't it
no actually officers have visited on
another occasion as well
so what did you say during august uh no
between um yes between january and
august
uh
observations by
sorry i was thinking september sorry to
answer your question yes during august
yes yes once
um have you been inside the premises
when it's operating
um
at all mr buckingham uh i've been inside
i don't know actually whether it was
open for business or not at the time i
attended there was nobody in there put
it that way
so but to all intents and purposes you
know i'd accept it wasn't operating at
the time yes so you're you can't speak
about your own personal experience and
uh as a as a professional officer of the
council about seeing what goes on inside
because you've never been there in the
evening is that right
not inside the premises no
um in relation to
um a graduated approach
um you've seen the timeline that i
mentioned
um and then the letter from simon bailey
advising noise complaints and mr wald
replied that was on the 15th of july
then there was a further letter on the
21st of july about further complaint not
substantiated he says
um
but
but mr ward replies speaks to mr bailey
and gives an explanation or gives an
explanation to what was said mr bailey
undertook to arrange a meeting to
discuss those issues
but no meeting was ever arranged and
followed up that was the 22nd july are
you aware that mr bailey
vowed to follow up a request for a
meeting face to face
i'm not sure why you're asking me that
question well you're the manager of the
department you deploy the resources
you've put yourself i don't manage mr
bailey it's a different department
so mr bailey is not in environmental
health no he's a planning uh enforcement
officer
all right dude so um
he
he says mr at i've got miss simon bailey
at environmental health advice and noise
complaints
sorry
i didn't quite hear that sorry
technically i think you said mr bailey
could you find it
at environment health advised of noise
complaints you're saying that that's
planning
um i i can't sorry i cannot speak for a
letter that mr bailey has written he's
in a different department i mean
obviously we we liaise um and he's well
aware that environmental health were
receiving noise complaints and likewise
i was well aware of the the planning
enforcement issues and there's dialogue
all the way through the investigation
yeah and on the fourth well well i've
got the list of the letters here so the
the next letter is on the fourth of
august james buckingham that's you right
to mr ward about noise
and mr walt replies to you saying please
cross-reference with mr bailey as these
issues have been raised to with him and
not had a reply and was talking about
having a meeting now you're wearing what
did you do about that reply on the 6th
of august from mr walt
uh what did i personally do
there was an officer receiving a reply
back from from the
sorry i think we're talking across
purposes
that letter was to mr bailey
i we have written to mr ward i think
when we we talked about this earlier on
in the hearing we went through all the
letters and sorry emails and letters
that um
either myself or mr cornish from
environmental protection have written to
your clients um there's been a number of
them on the sixth august yeah ed the mr
wall wrote ward wrote to you and asked
you to refer back to mr s bailey as
those issues have been raised in the
letters on the 15th
and the 21st of july and also made you
aware that there have been a request for
a meeting now what did you do
with his letter to you on the 6th of
august what steps did you take
because obviously we've heard from the
councillor
carpenter about what steps were you
taking to have
a discussion or a sit-down to try to
work up an action plan obviously they're
clearly engaging with you
um the mr walt wants to work with mr
bailey and with and you because he's
communicating and asking for a meeting
what steps did you take to arrange a
meeting
well uh sorry i've just obviously you've
caught me a little bit by surprise and
calling out a specific letter so i've
now had the opportunity to go back to it
uh call out myself so i'm happy to be
questioned on it um
so first find i mean the final letter
point says simon said that he would he
would convene a meeting with planning
and environmental health um so he's
awaiting a date from him so that's in
simon's hands
um i
you know i'm sorry that if that didn't
happen obviously um but what i would say
about that letter um in it was in
response to my email sorry an email not
a letter um an email exchange um is that
basically it's a
as chris cornish has said a flat denial
that there's a problem on the one hand
we're writing to your client saying
we've we've got evidence of these
problems
and what we receive in return is flat
denials and that's not that's not a a
way that i've ever gone about opening up
the dialogue it's not saying it's not
saying can we sit down and discuss this
it's saying no i'm sorry i don't we
don't agree with you i can read the
letter the email to you it's basically a
flat denial we therefore cannot point
one we can't accept this claim
point two
um about hand rise um we've changed
these hand dryers
uh antisocial behavior we're in contact
with the police have confirmed us that
we're running the venue well
um
i'm sorry they're just you know it's not
it's not it's not
talking about a stage approach i've been
doing this job for 25 years and i let me
please finish and i know when someone
wants to enter into dialogue and this
isn't the first this email that we're
talking about isn't the first occurrence
it's every single time we've emailed
your client we have had flat denials
that there has been a problem and that's
not a that's not how you go about
dialogue if someone isn't willing to
talk to you
then you cannot have a dialogue
and that's why quite frankly your client
has end we've ended up having to serve
an abatement notice on your client for
no other reason because we just haven't
been able to speak to them in a
in a in the
type of um
manner that you would expect with any
other business that we deal with it's
just not forthcoming from your client
i'm sorry
okay
mr chairman uh mr chairman look i i
asked the question about what did he
what did he do in relation to organizing
or responding to that letter
um
and the the officer has not not answered
that but but anyway i'll move on to my
next question um officer in relation to
uh you you say
no engagement but if if uh he the
premises is writing and emailing and
responding to you that is engagement it
might be that they don't accept what
you're saying but you're still having
dialogue yes or put it this way normally
what we what my experience is
in this case
about this case okay i will talk about
this case um
okay a flat answer to your question is
no
sorry we didn't we didn't have that
dialogue but that's this is two-way
street isn't you cannot have a dialogue
with someone who is just refusing to
accept the facts
that there are complaints being received
that six residents have complained to
the council
uh that we're having regular dialogue
with the police who are telling us that
they're overwhelmed by the amount of
reports coming to them in our meetings
that we have with police you cannot have
that dialogue unless somebody is the
other party is willing to to say okay
let's work together but so actually
could you show me one email from your
client that says should we have a
meeting and sit down and discuss this
with with you mr buckingham and your
team i could clearly see that you've had
you've written to mr
bailey requesting a meeting but that
wasn't to me
uh well uh i think it's probably a
misunderstanding with all due respect
perhaps there's a misunderstanding on
your part about
the structure of the council that that
may explain it i don't know i'm just
offering that art the um the environment
to health your department
as the sister assistant director you're
um
you've also though gone out to solicit
representation from the local police it
says um environmental health have asked
local police of any comments about an
application in relation to planning
and that you've asked them if they want
to comment
on
a planning application so environmental
health have gone out to the police
service
and asked them if they will make
representation or want to make comment
about planning applications i don't know
what you're alluding to is that is that
in your representation at all mr daniel
i'm asking you a question
sorry you're asking me about something
that i don't know anything about mr
chairman i'm asking a question and if
the officer doesn't know the answer fine
but can i finish the question sorry okay
so officer you're you're talking about
engaging with the police but it's right
that you've actually been going at your
department to solicit representation
from the police about these premises and
i was telling the police about an
application for planning do you not want
to comment on it do you know i really
don't know what you're referring to mr
dad sorry i'm i'm not making this up i
don't know what you're referring to
well i'll answer something that i have
no knowledge about right you have no
knowledge in your department
that your department is going out asking
the police if they want to make them
aware of an application and do they want
to comment about that application too
sorry which application are you
referring to planning application
because i'm under freedom of information
i think you probably you might want to
address this to mr cornish because i'm
sorry i cannot answer the i mean mr
corner has just put his hands up it
might be easier just to ask mr cornish
questions you're you're the you're the
manager of the department i'm asking do
you know in your department that your
officers have been going out soliciting
representation from the police on
planning are you aware of that
i don't believe i don't believe they
have
is the answer to that okay
that's the answer thank you i'll move on
now um
now you heard that your officer
les king
had made observations
uh in mr creswell's house
but his notes and and records have not
been disclosed in these
in this matter is that an usual approach
that the council will attend an officer
he makes observation makes notes and
records and and that is not included in
in these observations in this
application
mr king has actually
today you've heard from mr king he has
disclosed it he's told you what he
witnessed
yes but he's not his records have not
formed part of your your evidence you've
kept that back yes
no we haven't kept it back we as mr
cornish said we haven't project produced
160 page dossier of absolutely every
email and every
um pocket notebook entry um and every
record we have on our
email system on our
computer system we haven't produced that
because that's extremely um
can i finish the question please
statement well chair
he's asked me a question could i be you
know allowed to um answer it without
interruption yeah well keep the keep the
answers as brief as you can please i'm
trying to yes
and um
well i think it's already been actually
answered by mr cornish no we haven't
produced a dossier of absolutely every
shred of evidence and
log etcetera that um
we've had on this case no it would go
into volumes
yes
it is a summary of that because i don't
think the committee would thank us for
it if we did i didn't ask you about the
volumes and 200 pages i asked you about
one specific
with one specific visit
we've got the primary
applicant mr creswell a counsellor
your officer goes into his premises and
makes an observation chair i've been
cross-examined here evidence now i'm
asking the question that evidence
has not been disclosed why didn't you
disclose it the summary is in our
representation a summary of that visit
is in our representation we did disclose
it
right okay
his records of the meeting hasn't now in
relation to logs don't you think it
would be
appropriate the the logs or recording of
noise
um certainly that would be made
available
um um during this hearing even if it's
appropriately redacted they've not been
provided have they
no but that's been asked by mr cornish
no it's not it's not um no you're right
you're right we could have provided it
what we've provided
is the actual sound the actual sound
recordings that you can hear yourself if
you if you wish to
um and uh because because those sound
recordings go on for days and days and
days and days literally
um of
noise disturbance at your clients
premises
we've had to provide a summary of it
we've had no choice
and last question for you if i was to
play one of those recordings now or on
my machine yeah and turned up the volume
loud or turned it down low
however by listening to it how am i
supposed to determine whether it's loud
or not if i turn it up really loud it's
going to sound loud if i turn it really
down low it's going to sound low how can
i get any probative value from listening
to a recording um there's no there's no
sound levels on it
am i how am i supposed to be able to
listen to that and make a value judgment
and how are the councils supposed to do
that when you say go away have a listen
well can i explain
uh at the start of every recording that
we make there's a reference tone for a
start so you've got a recorded sound
level against which to
compare any um
noises that are recorded
um i wouldn't expect members to to
have that knowledge or expertise to be
able to look at that but factually
that's the case
and the other thing that um you will
hear on the recordings is mr dorrington
actually speaking to his wife because
he's been disturbed and woken up and
there you have it you have
a reference toe you have mr dorrington
speaking and then over the top of that
you have what's coming through his open
window
let me finish please let me finish he's
he's speaking at a volume just like well
actually probably not
quite volume just like we are you can
hear it yeah
my answer can i finish my answer please
i can answer another question now can i
finish my answer please chair all right
let him finish his answer
thank you thank you
you know you can hear on the recordings
mr dorrington speaking a a normal volume
in a conversational level and over that
you can hear the level of noise it's not
mr dorit mr dorrington can't cannot
physically up the volume of the
recordings he can't do it um it's
technically not possible so you have a
reference level and if you sat down and
you listened to those recordings as i
would urge members to do you will hear
that yourselves
all right thank you all right mr dads
please ask another one i'll i'll i'll
deal with the rest in closing
submissions as i say i think that the
order today has been highly prejudicial
uh and prejudicial to my client but i
won't i won't uh i'll deal with it in my
closing all right thank you right um mr
creswell would you like to ask any
questions
of um james buckingham
no i'm happy what mr buckingham
has said and i'm also pleased that he
was given the opportunity by the chair
and the councillors to speak because i
think that was needed and i think
everything should be transparent and
open and if it was it probably would be
over by now but i believe it's been held
up by mr dads because
this is another statement no there's no
need for that he doesn't want you to
hear all the evidence
i want to hear it and i want to hear it
fairly where's your logs where's your
recording where's the opposite statement
everybody please uh this is a question
and answer session can we stick to
questions and answers please and not
statements thank you mr chairman i
raised an objection please
yes mr dad
the the point i i
the reason why i raised my voice and
raised it is i i keep on having an
attack on
the applicant and my pr res presentation
like i just had there i've got to defend
the applicant and my reputation
about not disclosing i have genuine
concerns about failure of records not
being disclosed and being held back and
i think it is only right that i raised
that i've raised with you my objection i
accepted that you would allow the
officer to come back and i've done that
this was a question for the
environmental health and there was
another statement and another attack on
my character
it's right that i come in and say that's
not acceptable not fair
okay thank you well um constabulary is
there any questions from the
constabulary
no we have no questions to raise
right uh planning enforcement any
questions
uh thank you jan no no questions from me
thank you
right um go to the committee uh peter
have you got any questions for mr uh
just just a couple of points of
clarification to mr buckingham on what
he said
um
you did state uh in reply i can't
remember how you got to it but about the
noise and activity in that area um that
this is the worst it's been um and what
have you but can i just take you back
the great eastern pub
used to be on the corner there which i
would say is
not a hundred yards from this building
um i'm not sure of the exact figure but
certainly quite close they certainly up
until the time that they changed it into
flats that was the great eastern
nightclub
and there was noise there was activity
there was police activity
there was drugs some led to believe and
all sorts of things so i i just wanted
to be clear
that area has experienced
um noise and
upsetting scenes and and drugs and all
the other things
in the past
you made it sound like this was totally
something new that's never happened in
that area i'm not saying it was right
uh in the past
but i can certainly remember driving
down there and when i was younger
not going to the great east because i
was never young enough to go there
but
i saw all the people people queued out
and the noise and the carrying on and
what have you so just to be clear that
area has experienced that in the past it
may be before the time of some of the
residents that have ended up in boring
gate
uh precinct flats
so that was just a point there if you
wanted to clean the point the point i
was trying to make was
the borum gate precinct area
[Music]
no you made it seem as though it was
that area where that the great eastern
pub used to be that area i think but i
take your point you've clarified that
and the other one
just a little concerned
um
that um obviously
members of the council and officers of
the council i think we'd all encourage
each other to talk to one another and
try and solve these things before they
get out of hand
a little disappointed to hear you say
that
let's all work together and you were
saying he should have contacted you
uh
it's alleged that
um that the
mr ward contacted um the uh planning
officer
whether it was by mistake or an answer
to a letter and quite often when members
of the public get a letter from the
council they reply back and it perhaps
should go to another officer so i do
think that that may have been a
shortcoming with you um i don't know if
you've got to comment on that
it's not being disrespectful to you or
anything it's just that
let's all work together hedy contacted
me you were maintenance saying like if
you got in touch with you you definitely
made sure that you'd set up a meeting
yeah
i i think perhaps what's um being missed
is is the catalogue literally catalogue
of emails that you you haven't been
privy to i i you know to be fair to mr
dads you've not seen them i don't want
to comment too much but they were you
know i think i've alluded to two of them
earlier in the um
day one or day two of the hearing
there's been a
catalogue of email exchange between the
council sorry environment protection and
um
mr messes ward um and we just simply
have not had the cooperation that the
levels of cooperation that we get at any
other business that we deal with about
noise issues we just have not had that
um
so that that's my response thank you
thank you thank you mr pacquiao okay
peter well um sue carpenter have you got
any questions thank you chair yes
obviously as um
mr dad so mr buckingham have just said
there's a lot of correspondence that we
haven't been privy to
but um
james in the in the 24 years or so that
you've been working for baber
um
do you
recollect the um
great eastern pub that counselor beers
just referred to i do yeah uh the the um
there's a nightclub actually rather than
the pub yeah
oh okay a different premises different
type of premises and and what was the
hours of operation there and and is
there any recollection of disturbance in
the early hours of the morning
um
sorry it's asking a lot no i mean i
i would get i would guess somewhere
around two three o'clock in the morning
similar sort of time closure time um
certainly towards the end of its um
history
sorry um the other part of the question
i was really just trying to draw a
comparison if there were one
because obviously that's a nightclub it
was actually a nightclub where people
pay in and to go in and dance um much
like um
the infinity of the other end of uh
sudbury so they're not directly
comparable premises
um they're certainly not um
not to say that there weren't noise
complaints but whenever i had a lot of
dialogue with i desperately don't
remember his name another david um who
was the licensee there
yeah
father and son
what i would say is that um
although we had noise complaints we
entered into dialogue to address those
complaints and we never ever got to the
point
where we served abatement notices on
them we were able to deal with them
there might be a specific issue that
doors were being left open or whatever
and they were addressed that's not to
say that you know it's a completely
silent premises but we had a a
constructive working relationship with
that premises but nonetheless there was
significant disturbance yeah as there
are with an awful lot of the premises
both in sudbury and across baby suffolk
but it's that working dialogue that you
have with the with um your you know the
premises that we deal
with and that's
what we've not had on this occasion okay
thank you those are my questions chair
mr mr chairman i have remembered the
name but i don't know whether it's
necessary yes that's it you said i
didn't thank you
all right okay thank you um
points for clarification uh david price
got anything
jim i have no points for clarification
uh
right i'm glad we've uh done this so at
least we've heard everything and every
size now we're going to move on to the
planning enforcement officer to give his
report um simon bailey
uh thank you chair um i will just uh
read through my representation if uh if
that's acceptable to you and then if
there's any questions afterwards i'm
happy to answer as best i can
that's great thank you very much
okay so uh the planning enforcement team
has received a number of complaints from
members of the community local to the
licensed premises
raising concerns about the operation of
the premises and the behaviors exhibited
by patrons
the concerns
raised relate to the congregation of
patrons and others
outside the rear access of the premises
the rear access is used as an
alternative to the main front entrance
of the premises after 11 pm as required
by a planning condition
however the control exerted by the
management of the premises has uh
according to those
reporting concerns to us
resulted in resulted in public nuisance
issues particularly around noise
but also relating to odors
from
patrons uh vomiting and urinating in the
street in only ways adjacent to the
premises
um our complainants have also alleged
occurrences of
sex acts
contrary to public decency
further concerns raised by complainants
um refer to the attendance at the
premises of the police
uh the concerns raised by the complaints
relate to drug and assault-related cause
to the police and the frequency of
attendance by the police
planning enforcement enforcement has had
to refer these concerns onto colleagues
within the council as uh we have um
little to no direct influence over the
specifics
there are however some
related planning conditions which have
which have some relevance
in particular we've raised concerns with
the latency regarding
um the operation that the operation of
the establishment accords in all
respects
uh with the particulars of the noise
management and dispersal policy required
by condition 4
of their principal planning permission
and approved under a discharge of
conditions application
that the use of the main entrance doors
is restricted to emergency use only
between the hours of 11 pm and 8 00 am
in accordance with condition 9 of their
principal permission
and that the use of the premises as an
e-games lounge bar is restricted to the
hours provided for under condition 11 of
the planet permission
um in addition we expressed concern that
uh pre-commencement conditions attached
to the principal planning permission had
not been appropriately discharged as
required prior to opening of the
facility
uh whilst we acknowledged the licensee
has sought to discharge the conditions
the local planning authority has refused
in part
discharge of conditions
um specifically in relation to condition
5 for sound insulation and condition 10
the acoustic validation report
we are experiencing some reluctance on
behalf of the licensee to engage
effectively with us on these points
uh in conclusion um we remain concerned
that the facility is not being operated
in accordance with the approved noise
management and dispersal policy and this
is reflected in the congregations of
patrons and other people outside the
rear access of the property
we believe this is
an operational management issue
falling within the responsibility of the
business occupying the premises and is
giving rise to public nuisance
um we're also concerned that there is
creep in the use of the premises uh
specifically away from being a premises
used for e-gaming with an ancillary bar
facility and towards principally a
drinking establishment with ancillary
e-gaming element
that drift in the use is contrary to the
terms of the conditions of the principal
planning permission and we suspect it is
leading to disorder as a result of
excessive consumption of alcohol by
patrons
thank you chair
okay thank you very much um
david dads would you like to ask some
questions
yes mr bailey were you asked to make
representations uh by environmental
health officer in relation to this
review
uh was i asked to no i don't think so i
think i was made aware that this review
was happening and uh that i might wish
to make representations so i made a
presentation
and who did that who informed you
i believe it was david price the
licensing officer
right
in relation to planning planning
authority don't investigate complaints
from members of the public do they
about operational things like licensed
premises they might about it might
investigate breaches of planning but not
not
not operational
uh it depends on the planning conditions
if the planning conditions relate to
operations then yes we would
yes i won't
so
in relation to this premises
um the members of the public
how many members of the public have you
had call you from households
three
and how many from the precinct the um
precinct itself three
and
the in relation to enforcement have you
issued an enforcement notice
no
have you issued any breach of um
contravention notice i breach of
condition notice
no
um
do you except there has to be a
graduated approach to enforcement
yes
and i think that i've referred to you i
do apologize i didn't even realize it
was you i was referring to you earlier
on about letters written to you about
asking to sit down and have a meeting
you you're aware that the client is
asked to sit down and have a meeting to
you about planning
yes
and has that taken place yet
no uh a meeting has not been arranged i
am following the request from uh mr ward
i think it was uh mr ward senior
actually that i had i've spoken to i
don't think i've ever spoken to
william ward
uh there was suggestion of a meeting and
i did agree that i would um
speak to colleagues in
environmental protection and our
asset management property
team as well um as there is uh some
connection
uh with baby district council and the
building itself
um
having spoken to
um i believe it was it might have been
chris and james about this probably
separately
um i think the sense was that there
would probably be little me little merit
in in having a further meeting
um as mr buckingham's recently alluded
to uh there is there has been quite
extensive correspondence as i understand
it and previously a meeting on these
very subjects
um so it was felt that there was that
there would probably not be
much uh to be gained by having a further
meeting if i
if i've if i've if i've um uh failed to
communicate that back to mr ward then i
can only apologize okay so you were you
were in effect told by environment
health that they thought there was
little merit in in having a meeting
and by property yes and by our
colleagues in asset management they were
they were
um the feeling was that we would be
um
merely going around in circles on issues
that have already been covered
yes and in relation to
property
noise there's been an acoustic report
hasn't there
i believe that your client has prepared
an acoustic report to discharge the
conditions and i believe that was found
to be insufficient
but you've taken no further steps from
that
no well i haven't taken any further
steps from that um basically because uh
i was made aware of this
review of the licensing and if that was
going to resolve
uh the issues at hand then uh there
would be no further need for planning
enforcement to be serving notices
yeah and um so we've backed away from uh
pursuing uh formal notices at this point
on the basis that this review hearing
may actually uh seek to resolve the
issues at hand well you wouldn't do you
wouldn't go straight to a notice anyway
you'd have a meeting wouldn't you you'd
take a graduation
graduated approach that you that you're
referring to
is merely an engagement with the the
person responsible you wouldn't
necessarily have a meeting with them you
might engage in correspondence with them
by letter or by email you wouldn't
necessarily sit down and have a meeting
with them in every single case that we
ever come across no of course not and
but you nevertheless except that the
regulator's compliance code talks about
a graduated approach to enforcement and
before an enforcement notice is issued
unless it's so serious you would engage
by correspondence a graduated approach
yes
you would engage with the with the
person responsible for the breach yes
yeah uh the alleged breach and in
relation to the um here this premise is
at the moment the only premises that
uh that you've identified understand
that's affected is one dwelling one
premises is that right
no three we've had three complainants
you just asked me right now yes
complains about noise from operational
inside the building
planning inside the building
only one premises is effective with mr
dorrington that was the hand dryers and
the base is that
um
i'm not i'm not sure what you're asking
me i've had three people complain to me
about breach of conditions and some of
those
uh concerns related to noise um from
within the property
within the caffeine lounge and and uh
noise relating to um activities external
from the caffeine lounge
okay
but you've not provided any of that
information in your in your report
in which report in my representation
representation
uh correct
correct
um no further questions
all right thank you thank you um
mr creswell have you got any questions
for simon yes chair
mornings or afternoon now simon um i
have just a couple um one is um
as you're aware um
i
emailed you and
uh also
photographs and maybe videos to yourself
uh reference caffeine lounge in the
precinct not being shut by 11 pm and
that was probably december and the end
of march when the lockdown came
and mr ward had the key from the fish
and chip shop who used to shut at eight
and he
by i remember buying the uh platinum
which made the shutter 11 pm
and use the entrance from great eastern
road and that never happened would you
say i was right in what i was saying
thank you
um i recall uh receiving um
details from you including video one of
which showed
um the front entrance doors being used
after 11 pm
uh
yes i mean that that that was an
indication of a breach of planning
control that there was supposed to be
um
access only via the rear doors after 11
p.m
mr crazwell yes uh thank you simon all i
wanted to show to the councillors uh on
the panel is that
up until the end of march when we had
the covert and we had the lockdown the
precinct never shut until the caffeine
lounge went home and it could have been
four in the morning and inside that area
if you imagine it's like a little
football ground it's a
it's got a canopy go all the way around
and the noise and the echoes and the
shell and the disturbance in there was
horrendous thank you very much thank you
thank you
thank you um
constabulary have you got any um
questions
yes just a couple um can i clarify
when the application was first made for
a premises license
there was a meeting was planning part of
that meeting
uh i'm unable to answer i'm afraid
i wasn't involved in the
licensing or
principal planning applications or any
of the discharge of conditioned
applications my involvement has been um
regarding complaints of non-compliance
with the permission so i've come to it
after the event
so to speak
all right i don't know if you'll be able
to answer this then my next question was
be will planning have agreed to a 330
hour closing time for the premises seven
days a week
if the applicant had not assured them
that it was only going to be open to
then occasionally for the purpose of
hosting a gaming event
um i can't answer to the specifics uh
other than to say that it strikes me as
a professional planning officer that
will be unlikely that you would give
planning permission for opening times to
3 30 a.m without a very good um
uh uh very um
uh reason for doing so
okay no that's a lot from the police
thank you
thank you um uh
any questions from environment
mr
cornish yes just a couple quick ones um
simon are any of the conditions that
you've been investigating requiring
agreement of details prior to the
commencement of either development or
prior to the opening of the premises
uh yes i believed uh two of those
condition five and condition 10 were
pre-commencement conditions prior to the
facility
and are you aware as to whether the
planning officer or the planning manager
isabelle had any
meetings and dialogue with the license
holder concerning these matters since uh
december and january
um i don't know what period they've had
meetings uh i'm i'm i've got a vague
recollection that they'd have had
meetings about the discharge of the
conditions uh but what the outcomes to
those meetings was i couldn't tell you
i'm afraid
thank you
no further questions thank you
i've got a question for you and
isn't it down to um the landlords which
would be baby district council to um
close the precinct at 11 o'clock and
it's through a management company
not relying on
dishing out keys to hit the fish and
chip shop and the
is that you or can you answer that one
yeah i i i don't think it's really one
for me to answer uh if i'm on honest
counseling newman but um my
understanding was that um
that
from information was new from elsewhere
that um uh the precinct wasn't being
closed at 11 pm
um i would uh i would expect that it
would be um our responsibility as the as
the landowner to be able to uh to have
that um closure
uh performed at at the right time and i
believe that that is now happening
um through a management company yes
yeah because i believe that's the root
of a lot of trouble we had from the
start that we we weren't shutting it
properly on time you know
that's what
that may well be enough um
it should be locked up and and we should
have the keys to it okay um i think that
possibly is um is resolved
okay good okay peter uh thank you um
hello simon um
just a couple of
clarifications really one
um
being involved in planning i would
expect you as a planning enforcement
officer to comment on an application if
you were so asked by whoever asked you i
would i would just expect that to happen
so i don't think there's anything
sinister there at all um the other thing
that i'm a little disappointed in is the
fact that
um
[Music]
i know you you'd like to talk to people
and engage with them to try and solve
these problems before they get too far
out of hand and we have to take a
um
a heavy hammer to something um bert
sorry
medication alarm sorry not a phone call
but um my point is that um
would you not say
uh that it's better to try and have head
that meeting or i know covert came along
and it's most likely upset it but i
think a meeting um
face to face would have been quite
useful but
and this isn't something that you would
normally not do i i'm led to believe in
myself can you just comment on that
uh yeah i mean the the correspondence
that went to um the licensee uh was
postcoded actually so it was july and
august that um we were in contact with
the
uh with the licensee so that wouldn't
necessarily have been a bar to
having that meeting but
uh and you're right we wouldn't normally
um
seek to resolve these things through a
negotiation with um
the the the person's responsible but
um the information that i was receiving
um from environmental health from asset
management and
uh to some extent from my own research
of what has happened with planning
applications was that there was um quite
a lot of engagement with this
uh with this licensee um around how to
get these things resolved uh already and
it seemed to me
on the advice from colleagues that it
would offer little merit to go over that
ground once more
um and that's and that's common to a lot
of our enforcement cases we don't tend
to
uh it's less than ideal let's put it
that way to keep going round and round
uh in negotiations you have to stop
negotiating at some point and you have
to get
uh the thing actually resolved so so if
if parties are not willing to engage
with us and they're not willing to
negotiate with us
then you know we'll rapidly get to the
service of a notice if we can see some
progress we're willing to hold off
service of a notice
now um i appreciate that those comments
probably fly in the face of uh what mr
daz might have um said earlier about uh
his um client wanting to have a meeting
with us
um and my unfortunately uh not advising
that we didn't think there was any merit
in that
but nonetheless it is still within the
licensees gift to be able to progress a
further discharge of condition
application
if they were comfortable and confident
that
that that that was going to get passed
they could have submitted that and and
that would have certainly gone some way
to
resolving the non-compliance with
conditions five and ten for the noise
insulation and the acoustic validation
report
um in safari's uh use of the um
uh the the rear doors in favor of the
front doors after 11 pm
uh you know we've had information from
um our property team that have indicated
that we now have the management company
in place that is locking it up at 11 p.m
so
so that breach has been resolved
um we still have some concerns around
the
noise management and dispersal policy
and compliance with that
um
and also the um the the restriction on
the use of the premises but you know
with with this hearing
being booked in and i think it's been
delayed two or three times so
you know that's that's um not assisted
us particularly in planning enforcement
in progressing things we don't really
want to uh
start taking uh formal action by way of
the service of notices if there is
another mechanism which could uh resolve
these issues so we've held off um uh
pushing for um notices because we are we
are aware that this is happening and
this might be a solution
thank you for that um that was very good
answer and uh um what i would expect uh
from you um just one other point and you
may have answered it in in that last
question uh is that uh you did
you put it very politely
and i will as well outside activity uh
going on around the premises um
how how much store
is that the responsibility of the
um
of mr ward the catholic lounge people
uh well i mean i think um
the noise management and dispersal
policies is the relevant uh
mechanism for um controlling that
that
sort of thing
mr ward i don't think can be responsible
for what everybody in sudbury is doing
but the noise management and dispersal
policy um indicates and this is you know
approved through a discharge of
condition application as well
um but it talks to
getting people to leave the premises
in a way that's going to minimize um
disturbance or nuisance to local
residents
um and
and and says that staff
on duty would would monitor
um the activity of patrons who are um on
their way out of the premises and and
and assist with managed departure
so you know and in conjunction with that
to um have those persons leaving
reminded to act in a responsible manner
so
you know if those if those things are um
not happening then then people um
engaging in you know sort of public
nuisance or or um
acts that might be contrary to public
decency
you know
we accept um
uh that mr ward can only be held
responsible in so far
but if the management of the property um
and the and the premises as the e-gaming
lounge is going on effectively and
properly and appropriately
then those people probably shouldn't be
in that area
thank you very helpful thank you all
right
sue carpenter have you got any questions
uh thank you chad just briefly because i
think um simon bailey has has touched on
some of the areas i was interested in um
you're talking about planning condition
nine and prohibiting access to the
precinct um
i mean it's not just people coming in
and out of the precinct is it
um because that needs to be locked up
it's people using the door perhaps to go
out and smoke in the precinct that's
that's a breach isn't it
that would be yes i mean i think from
the information that we've had there
were people that um occasionally there
were people who were who were using
uh the precinct as a as a shortcut
and also there was some
egress
[Music]
entry and egress to caffeine lounge via
the front doors after 11 p.m
through the through the shopping center
and the planning condition was was that
it should not be used after 11 pm is
that correct well yeah the planning
condition obviously is is applicable to
the caffeine lounge because planning
permission only relates to them yeah
they shouldn't be using their front
entrance door after 11 p.m but um it
wouldn't be the responsibility of
caffeine lounge to make sure that nobody
went through the shopping center
yes but if that door is being used after
11 then it's in breach
um
you've mentioned one or two other
planning conditions here
um was the required sound installation
installed within the premises that
refers to condition five
um
i i think it i i'm assuming that it has
been installed um on the basis that the
licensee has uh sought to discharge the
condition okay but i think we um and you
know we would have consulted um
for uh expert opinions through um the
environmental health team
on on whether or not the details
provided as part of that discharge of
condition application were satisfactory
and i my understanding is that it it was
um considered to be insufficient
uh to give the comfort that the the
sound insulation had been um installed
correctly
so uh so i believe that condition 5 for
sound insulation and condition 10 for
the acoustic validation report
were both uh not discharged through that
application
so that's kind of ongoing
they are still outstanding as i
understand it yeah i don't think any
further applications have come forward
okay
um given this um this issue about the
noise and dispersal of customers
what is your evaluation
of your response to condition 4.
what is my evaluation of my response of
of the response from the premises the
licence holder the business regarding
how they manage the noise and dispersal
of people
their response uh was essentially to say
that they were doing everything they
needed to
but did you agree with that
no
thank you
my questions mr chairman
okay thank you um i think uh david uh
dad's got his hand up is that have you
got another question david or have you
just left your hand up
no i've got a couple questions from
following what what's been asked if i
may be permitted
yeah yeah i allowed that yeah
mr bailey
hello hello uh my understanding from my
client is that actually condition five
and ten has now been or had been agreed
by environmental health i i don't know
with have you heard whether there's been
an agreement with environmental health
in relation to those conditions now
um i haven't
uh
but like you say that's a planning
that's a planning issue in relation to a
breach
um
the uh council was asking you if someone
was for egress obviously the doors got
to be left open for an emergency door
yes
to the precinct
um if
well
it's allowed to be used for emergency
yes
um
yes i believe so
yeah so it's it's a pirate though so if
someone opens it and goes out obviously
um
the um
it's not generally open for egress and
ingress but but but obviously that you
wouldn't consider that a breach would
you
if it was used in an emergency
yeah no i wouldn't or someone yeah
and then um in relation to
if jesus just by patrons
uh then that would be a breach if it's
um if it's being used for an emergency
reason whether emergency services
require access or egress through that
door
um or if somebody was perhaps injured
within the premises and needed to be
removed uh quickly or to maintain their
safety or well-being then yes that would
that would constitute the emergency use
but just customers coming and going
wouldn't would it no but it but what i'm
trying to establish from you is that the
door has to remain unlocked it can't be
simply locked
uh as a solution to stopping people
people using it it has to be
allowed to be opened in an emergency so
it has to have a certain lock on it
which obviously a customer could
potentially open it and even though
they're not permitted go out through
that route
yes that's true i mean the condition
doesn't say that the door must be locked
it says it shall not be used for access
so that's right then the onus then is on
the um
of the premises to um make sure that
that is adhered to
well yeah
i mean
if you
need to lock the door it might be to do
something else yes um signpost you know
uh in front of the door on both sides
internally and externally to make sure
that people are aware they shouldn't be
using it yes but in relation to um the
the
alleged breach even if we say it's
breached
have you written to the premises and
started to take action about that breach
or you you've not even started a process
because it's not really material
in that sense it's not got to that level
because i think you said it's now been
resolved
the uh issue with the doors yeah
uh i believe i raised it in a letter to
to um the licensee
but it's been resolved now there's no
enforcement action on it no
no
um
and in relation to
the complaints
you asked about the goings on outside
have you actually investigated and
cooperated whether in these complaints
from your view happened or not have you
actually gone out to investigate or is
that outside your remit
in relation to
uh which aspects complaints in the
public
have you been out to investigate to see
whether um the validity of those
complaints have i been out to
investigate if somebody's having sex
outside the caffeine lounge at three
o'clock in the morning no i haven't
no
officer i'm not being i'm not being um
i'm not being funny i'm saying you've
had a complaint that someone entered
into sexual intercourse outside the
premises
your department you've received that
complaint what do you do to investigate
whether that is one
has happened
um or not whether it's linked to the
premises or not because it could be a
member of the public coming home from
somewhere else it could be a licensed
premises and unlicensed premises or
coming back from one residential house
it could be young people uh wanting to
can't go home whatever it may be how do
you have you investigated with that
is linked to the premises and is it in
your remit normally to go out and
investigate or are you taking a full
face value that these things have
happened and we're responsible
uh i'm not i'm not sure how i would uh
investigate those particular issues in
order to establish whether they'd
happened or not i mean not sure what
evidence would remain that that would be
uh that i would be able to establish um
yes ordinarily we would go out to
investigate such issues uh relating to
um breaches of planning control uh we
don't just rely on the information that
a complainant has brought forward to us
but it depends what the information is
the information is that people are um
being noisy in the early hours of the
morning i'm not sure that we would be
able to go out and confirm that that
happened
with people um
urinating or vomiting in the street i
suppose we might be able to go out and
find some evidence of that
um but you know if it rains between us
receiving the complaint and us managing
to get to site we're probably not going
to find anything have you actually
invested in
what we're concerned about is the fact
that we've had a complaint which relates
to some of the conditions of the
permission
one of those being that the noise
management dispersal policy
uh required by condition for and
discharged under a a separate
application is not being adhered to so
um what i've done simply is draw that to
the attention of the licensee and
requested that they ensure that they do
accord with the
with the with the particulars of the
policy that they've written
and put forward as a as a means of
discharging that condition
and so that they are able to take the
steps that they need to to make sure
that the premises is managed correctly
yes but also it goes back to the
question i asked you
in any of these three complainants about
their complaints of any of those
have you
investigated any of those
just
yes i have yes because the investigation
is that i've uh taken the steps to
contact the licensee and draw that to
their attention so that they can resolve
it yeah but you haven't you haven't
investigate whether there's a direct
calls or link or just ask the licensee
so for example have you gone along and
requested cctv to see if what has been
complained of outside is actually
occurring because they've got cctv have
you done that
no
no so other than notifying the premises
that there's been a complaint you've
done no further steps to see whether
cooperate or check the validity of that
complaint
uh
no
i've drawn it to the licensee's
attention that we've had complaints that
there are issues that may need to be
resolved and
i've left the the ball in their court to
confirm that those are
um
being the things they need to adhere to
are being adhered to and that there is
no breach
and but in relation to the complaint
it's an alleged complaint and until it's
corroborated or established to be true
it's only an allegation isn't it
yes
thank you no further questions mr
chairman
okay
mr chairman can i speak quick
yeah right
yeah
yeah mr dad's had a question if it's a
question mr queswell i'm not a statement
mr dad said uh alleged i would say the
photos i said mr bailey would have said
it wasn't alleged it was fact thank you
all right thank you right i think um
we've had a good report from simon who's
uh waited quite a long while to do this
uh before we go to closing submissions i
think we'll have a half hour lunch break
and then we'll go to closing submissions
just one thing david price have you got
any points of clarification
no chair i don't have any points of
clarification okay so we're um closed
for half an hour what should we say uh
what's it seven minutes 20 to two is
that okay that sounds lovely all right
thank you all right
welcome back everybody um just before we
go to club closing submissions um simon
bailey's got um a couple of points for
clarification simon
uh yes thank you chair um whilst we've
been on lunch break i've just had to
look on our planning record to see if
there has been a further application to
discharge the conditions for the
property and i can't find a record that
one has either been submitted or
approved
and also i just would like to take the
opportunity to follow up on mr dad's
point about whether or not an allegation
um
has been um verified uh some of the some
of the complaints we received were
accompanied by uh video evidence which
indicated that the front door was being
used after 11 pm
and also indicated the congregation of
um patrons and other people around the
rear of the premises
uh as well so just to just to clarify
that those
um allegations that we received were
actually corroborated by uh the
information that we received at the same
time thank you chair
okay
mr dads do you need to comment on that
no i deal with it in my cozy okay okay
right we'll go to closing submissions so
it'll be the applicant mr creswell would
you like to do your closing submission
yes i'll do that chill
right um i'll start right at the
beginning um november december when the
caffeine lounge got the application in
to open the bar
um
it was noisy over christmas and precinct
was open although it was meant to shut
at 11 and the doors were open to the
caffeine lounge premises
people come and went and there was lots
of noise
in january
i was woken it was christmas holidays i
was woken three nights on the trot i
think it's a thursday
wednesday thursday friday night
stroke saturday morning
and on that saturday morning on the 4th
of january i went down to see mr ward
i walked into the precinct i'm quite
happy for all of you to do these videos
that uh mr ward uh
through the town council baber and tried
to get me into trouble i went
uh to the doors in the precinct and the
doors shut but i could see people in the
building so i went to great eastern road
i know the door was open not locked open
i undone the handle walked in and spoke
to mr ward's manager bar manager uh mr
lorenzo and asked if i could speak to
william this is how the conversation was
i then spoke to william and i complained
about the doors not shutting in the
precinct at 11 and how i'd been woken
every night for three nights on the trot
between 12 and 3 in the morning i can't
remember the times
mr ward got angry because
he said i can't have this open with you
know my business won't work if i haven't
got those doors open
i then
informed him that
my neighbors up here were getting woken
up and what i turned round and said my
polish neighbors
he's not going to be happy if his
children keep uh being woken up and
you're going to end up in a situation
where people come down to see you at two
three in the morning and it's going to
get out of hand it was absolutely
absolutely no mention of a weapon a poll
that mr dad said was outrageous i said
my polish neighbors
absolutely different to what mr dads
have said
i was then
investigated by my town council and by
baby and i was exonerated rightly so
because i'd done nothing i was
exonerated i was not charged by the
police because it's absolute fabrication
and i'm afraid to say mr ward has a
habit of that
and we'll carry on so anyway
all the way up to the end of march the
doors on the precinct never shut
i never spoke to mr dads anymore uh mr
dads i apologize mr ward anymore because
i thought
i tried to sort it out like
you might say counselors as an
individual trying to get
as
the environmental people say i was
wasting my time speaking
with mr ward i tried to do it in a way
that he would shut the precinct up
and
it would have took the noise away that i
was suffering and everybody was
suffering from within the precinct
anyway end of march comes
and he opens on the 4th of july
now by then mr ward hasn't got the keys
i agree he had them between december and
he had him to the end of
march previously the chip shop had shut
that precinct at eight o'clock when they
finish their house never an issue never
a problem shut all day on sunday i think
you all know the routine
it opened up in july
and
uh at times the precinct was shut at 11
by the uh the company brought in to do
it there was occasions where it was a
bit late but i haven't got a problem
with that
but
what happened there was a loophole let's
be honest the nightclub infinity was
shut the bars were shut at 12 and he was
open till 3 p.m 4 p.m whatever time it
might be
and the noise
you talk about noise i it was like being
a football ground only in your house
i took videos i sent to the police on my
phone i sent to the council i sent to
catherine green
licensing department i sent some to
simon baby because i wanted this resort
resolved now
i had abuse
from mr ward at my shouting up at my
windows when we put a false camera up
and our life in this area has been hell
now i've only lived here four years now
in that four years
it's been
relatively peaceful now i know it's town
center i agree
but
let's be honest there is no noise in
this area unless or when the caffeine
lounge is open
and until late at night and let's let's
also be honest although
uh the police
i think it was 34 or 39 cases and mr
dad's put said eight worth nothing to do
it still leaves 30. and it wasn't in a
year let's be honest
three months or two or three months for
covid
and another month it was shut at 10
o'clock because the government shut
things down at 10.
so whenever
he has really been open six months seven
months and in that time there's been 40
visits by the police what don't matter
how you dress it up
and as for the great eastern it was 15
years ago and
the great eastern didn't have neighbours
live above the premises
now when it comes to mr dorington being
the only one to have
the sound equipment put in i'll explain
next door
hasn't even got anybody living it has
been vacant for two years so
there would have been no one to push the
button on and next door the chat isn't
very well so there's three places live
above
the caffeine lounge and the only one he
could really use was mr dorington
because one was vacant and matt who
lives at 20a isn't well and he's got
young children
so
that's the case
there's no there's no pass and footage
we haven't got people walking down to
waitrose at 12 o'clock now and we never
had before before the caffeine lounge
opened
this is all related to the through the
business as people say this is a drink
and establish not a gaming bar
i have no problem with mr ward running a
gaming bar i
i tried i came to the first hearing
perhaps
i did ask to speak at that hearing i i
wasn't allowed and i watched the meeting
on youtube
but my
my
gripe isn't with the what type of
business and it's not mr ward it's being
woken up at night
and
no it's not as environmental says this
isn't friday and saturday this is
five nights a week six nights a week you
get the odd good night but it was
absolutely horrendous i must have 20
videos on my phone and more photographs
that i have sent to the relevant people
including the police
i i just feel he's been totally totally
unapproachable in a moment you're gonna
get it dressed up but you can't dress up
what's happened here if you lived here
you'd be exactly how i feel how the
other residents feel
now as for mr dadsan
me mr dorington there's eight properties
on the king
on the great eastern road above
not all above him three above mr ward
and five that face onto the road
every household every household except
number 20 and
20b were empty
every
household have put a complaint in every
household i've sent the noise assessment
in where they were being woken so this
isn't me
what it is
you don't understand the process i never
yes and mr dad say i'm a counselor yes i
am a counselor i'm not concerned not but
it needed
up here
there's only me and
three of us
who are good with english
and to to do this type of thing so hard
for people they don't understand they
don't know how to complain they don't
know where to go
and people watching this on youtube
if you i hate to say this but if you
make the wrong decision and let this
carry on they're going to think really
why do i ever bother to go to the
council why do i bother when this kind
of thing can go on it it's shameful
there's no way you can dress it up mr
dads can dress up how we like you can
say this happened that happened
let's be honest let's be honest the
police went in there they found vaseline
all over the windowsill
cocaine on the toilet paper the next day
more of a youngster go in there to play
a game if he says it's a gaming bar and
then where did that cocaine go off the
toilet roll onto their fingers
we know what go on
i know a hundred percent what go on i
know what went on on the 29th they can
they try and frighten me i'm not scared
because
they've done it to many people it's all
it's horrendous they've mr ward and his
mother i got the video so i gave him to
the counsellor about going to her
workplace in richardson sudbury and
making threats to a lady i got the crime
number
it's constant it's not just me fellow
counselors have been
threatened by
emails or by facebook i don't do
facebook i don't do social media because
it's just something
that could cause me more hassle
this needs resolving
i'm not worried if if the business i
don't want you to close a business down
that that's not what it's about
but
the hours they have to be changed it
can't carry on how it has been
it's so unfair on the people who live
here and the people who lived here
before the caffeine lounge opened
dress up how you like
it's not football it's nothing to do
with cars
it's to do with people coming into the
premises leaving the premises hanging
around
there's no good the doorman they'll sit
over always smoking and drinking the
doormen weren't even affiliated
let's be honest they weren't even on a
license
now he wants to do things properly i
think it's a little bit too little a
little bit too late
i'll let mr dads have it because i'd
like me tea thank you very much
okay well thank you mr cruz as well
now um licensing officer david price
will give a closing statement david
thank you i'll be brief
um just to say that you've heard a lot
of evidence you've got a lot of
supporting evidence for you to go
through
and
in your
decision-making obviously the officer's
report sets out um steps for you to take
or not take in the process of your
decision making so 2.1 2.2 and 2.3
uh part of your decision-making exercise
and i will just say one last part for
clarification that i heard during the
hearing and that was that my name was
mentioned as part in the planning
presentation um so it looked like the
licensing authority had solicited
representations that is not the case the
licensing authority had provided
the review papers in accordance with
statutory time scales thank you jim
okay thank you david right now for uh
the premises license holder or the
representative which is um
davey dads to present his closing
statement please
thank you mr jim and i and i think i'm
the last speaker is that right yes you
are yes well um
it's going to take me um a little bit of
time to go through but i'm going to
hopefully uh narrow down all the
evidence that we've heard over the three
days well i apologize i've forgotten to
put my tie on after lunch
um just seeing the screen um i will
continue if you don't mind me not being
happy please do there are so so the
first thing is
let's deal with um uh mr crosswell
councillor cresswell he says i'm going
to dress it up
um
and that um
in essence i'm going to in effect play
down he's he's evidence
um well he says let's be honest well
hang on a minute yes
let's be honest let's deal with the
first thing he deals with which is
the visit to the premises on the 4th of
january he's just told you
um
i i was talking about my polish neighbor
and their children and they're being
affected and we would come down
and he he recites the conversation but
i've sent you already the transcript of
the conversation he doesn't realize
perhaps that every word is recorded
he says
uh
asked he entered into the back of the
building it was closed by the fire exit
and he was asked to leave because the
premise was closed not open to members
of the public including him
i'm going to have to ask you to leave
okay i will take it to arthur who i have
spoken to arthur being the chief
executive
so he he's threatening i'm going to take
it to the chief executive as my client
sees it
um
you can take it to wherever you want
trevor this is a fire risk to keep the
door uh shut and i was just talking
about it was open well no the fire exit
door has to be accessible that's what
they're talking about
all right
but at the moment um you should uh put
up a sign so talking about the fire exit
again
then they go on
and he says um
i've got four councillors two of them mr
osborne so they're talking he's now not
only talking about the chief executive
he's talking about getting counsellors
on board and he's been told well you're
going to have to do what you what you
wish to do if you want to take it
further
then he's asked to leave and then he
goes on to say
uh
that um right if i'm woken up every
night i'm gonna come down
and see you you will understand if i'm
woken me in the poll if you like to come
and see you and we will deal with you in
another way
if you don't want to deal with it in my
way
i'm not going to be woken up in the
summer every night
so there was a threat
and and i didn't and that is the
recording of the conversation nowhere
does it say about the neighbor the
children the polish neighbor
and it asks and he makes it very very
clear
um i won't i'm not i'm going to take it
to arthur
and i'm going to try and get your
license revoked
that's what he said on the 4th of
january
yet frets
frets made using his influence as
councillor with the chief executive
threats of his uh
he influencing other councillors
to uh help him
and and a clear threat that he's going
to revoke the license he's going to get
the license revoked that's on the 4th of
january
so let's be honest
that's right let's be honest well the
inversion of events he's just given you
is completely contrary to the actual
recording of cctv and audio which has
been provided
uh he's credibility is shot basically
because he's not being honest with you
uh in relation to the application
uh the application itself has a number
of failings
the
so
on page
of the um application
it refers to the 26th of july
but there's a fight outside you remember
an ambulance
but this was an unrelated matter whether
we had called the police he hadn't
witnessed it
um he's put down these times but
actually luckily for enough and luckily
for us
we had the police records that showed it
wasn't anything like that so this is not
true
he's seen the police outside i would um
suggest and make an and not witness to
fight but put that down no there's no
video evidence at all that you've got of
a fight none
all of these videos you look at them
there's no evidence of any fights
and there is actually evidence the
police being present at um ten past
three and not witnessing or seeing any
of that he says ah what it may have
happened outside away from the premises
no the police are on the premises
yes
um in relation to the next matter the
31st of july
called police fight outside uh 18
minutes past two
and we know that there was an incident
across the road but it was after three
o'clock didn't even correspond with the
time not even related to the premises
and later on at the bottom 31st drive
police called
fight caffeine lounge referring to the
matter above he didn't witness it and
then he said oh actually
it did it definitely was the premises
and then he says oh it's tom
he's all over the place mr chairman with
his evidence yet because he's just
seeing what's outside and trying to link
it because you heard him he said nope
there's no other reason why anyone else
would be outside and then he had to
accept well there are other people
outside but only 10 maybe one in ten
but the thing is he is blindsided he has
a complete bias
he's been spoken to the police for using
the threatening behavior yeah and don't
do it again
um he's already threatened to revoke the
license and invoke all the powers that
he has as a counsellor to influence
others
you've just heard him in his closing
he's used his power to have access to
licensing officers he's used his power
to have access to
the police
the chief executive he says he's spoken
to he's used his influence to try to get
what he wants which is this license
revoked
surprisingly though mr chairman
he's had officers in his flat
he's had the minis flat doing
observations
he said in his evidence
no
i've had no officers in my flat we we've
i've gave you the transcript uh he
actually said that he had no officers in
his laptop i'll just get the
transcript to that
says um
bear me one minute
i just need to find that part one moment
please
at three
three hours 28 minutes in the recording
of the first hearing um
i've said um
to a number of questions
um
i'm i'm just asking that you
you completed blogs recorded dates time
and sent those to the local authority
they haven't
you don't seem to see them in the agenda
he says no i don't see them in the
agenda
no you have had officers visit your home
particularly in the bedroom late at
night monitoring the sound installing
installing noise monitoring equipment in
your bedroom
he says there's been no monitoring
of sound in my house
that was his reply
so is he lying
because it's very important
or are the officers lying
or actually is it a mixture of both
that they're misleading you
officers have been in his flat and i
believe it because two officers say they
have
les king said he has
he made notes he made observations
none of that evidence has been disclosed
there's a slight reference to her
statement which i'll come back to
but it hasn't been disclosed
mr krebswell has supposedly filled out
logs noise recording records
and dates times
none of that has been provided to you
none of that has been provided to us
because clearly we do have recording
equipment we have cctv we have audio
equipment so we can go and say did that
happen or didn't happen because we've
got the systems to check
something's gone on here
which is um you'll have to make a
judgment on but mr creswell
has
made an application
he's made threats of using his influence
to get revocation he's had offices in
his flats
and he's flat but none of those officers
recordings have been made available
no record has been made available
mr doctor
councillor cresswell
has denied that having ever having
officers in was that because he knew
that the evidence that they had
collected hadn't been
sufficient
doesn't do the job
so it's never been disclosed because
they've been in you would expect them mr
chairman
a councillor having this influence the
officers have been in nothing
because i tell you what as you all know
if there was anything you'd have it
absolutely you'd have it if there was
anything against the premises about how
it operates at the back
you would have that evidence against us
from the applicant the counsellor
the neighbor facing great eastern road
the only neighbour facing great eastern
road in this
review no evidence at all
what you do have as evidence is
vexatious
threats
threats have influence threats have
revoked
the license and
inappropriate conduct and behavior
now what do we have if we move on then
to
uh mr dorington
he has a recording machine in his home
everyone knows about it well everyone in
a sense that needs to know mr cresswell
knows about it tom cresswell will know
about it they all know it about it
what's quite fascinating is that the
machine is put there it it doesn't have
eyes
it can't work out
it records noise but i can't tell you
where it's coming from
and
what's quite surprising the officers
have never been
never been to what they tell us
they've never been never been
to observe
monitored with the machine
to see whether actually the noise that's
recording
where's that what is that noise source
where did they go
what were they doing that would be
i would say normal practice
because they're cooperating
what the machine is hearing
and also to double check that maybe no
one is abusing that machine because
obviously if someone knows it's in place
the officer accepts it can be
manipulated
because it's their recording you click
it you can make a noise outside
that's it and you can repeat that
process if you know it's over a weekend
right come on we want this closed let's
get on with it let's make a racket for
the weekend let's try to make sure we
make a noise
and we go click click click
i think
it can be manipulated mr chairman
and there is no there is no cooperating
evidence from the officers about that
machine
and all that machine can tell you
is that there is a noise but he can't
tell you whether it is somewhat
unconnected with the premises so someone
walking by using the alleyway and we've
got evidence of that that shows there
are matters of arising that are not
connected
it could be
malicious
and and obviously i have to accept some
noise could be from us
but you can't work out what is what
isn't
now
in relation to mr dorrington
and the officers
offers have only been to these premises
once
to observe it during its operation in
the evening
so from
january all the way around to
um
this review hearing where evidence can
be served only one observation
has been provided to you and undertaken
that's it
so and that observation you'll find in
the pack i'll deal with that now
excuse me chair sorry to interrupt mr
dad i was just wanting to check that um
counselor beer's video is on
yeah i can see your everybody i i can't
see you peter oh there you are sorry
about that
i i haven't done anything i'm just
sitting here and i can see myself and i
can see everybody else
thank you so the only observation
made by officers can be found at page
36.
and it's the four paragraphs
where the the environmental health
officers are there from 12 to court past
at midnight
approximately six people outside
uh roped off area
noise was good uh good-natured but
likely to be audible in in nearby
bedrooms they didn't go into nearby
bedrooms
approximately caught past individual
small groups coming from king street to
cafe lounge sometimes concreting the
street before entering
um now we have uh then the comments uh
quarter to one saying
15 to 20 people good natured outside but
likely to disturb inside the flats
but remember we don't have any
observations within the flats they've
been inside and ops and made
observations but not provided the
records mr chairman
they're saying well this might disturb
people in the flats they've been in the
flats and provided no evidence of what
they found in the flat
then they go on to say no visible audio
attempts staff to ask people to be quiet
to reduce the noise and then they then
there's a comment of whilst inside a
flat they look at what happens in the
precinct
but that is all
that they recalled
as going on inside the flat
flat
and all that's going on in their
observation that's the out everything
you've got so throw enough mud and hope
some of it sticks let's just get this
absolutely straight in your records
there's only been one visit
one observation by officers and that is
it
and there's not been one bit of drop of
evidence of what noise can be heard in
the flats from great eastern road
now they've been in but they're not
sharing the evidence with you
or shared that evidence with us
now i would say the reason they haven't
done that is because it doesn't help
their case
now in relation to the um noise
we've we've broken it down before
you've got inside the premises
outside the premises now inside the
premises
we've already heard evidence from the mr
cresswell that inside he's not troubled
by the operation inside
the officers have not been inside
mr cresswar has no issue with operation
inside the police have not been inside
the police officer here has not been to
the premises
inside operationally
there are no issues of concern
that need to be taken the police say
obviously you you're reporting and i'll
go and cover what the police say about
operationally but inside regarding noise
there is no complaint other than the
hand drivers dryers which were resolved
and it's got a noise limited that can be
set
now noise outside
there was the noise inside the precinct
and the noise a great eastern road that
was alleged
now in relation to the precinct we know
pretty much that has now been resolved
by the management company locking up the
precinct we also know that we have now
put a lock on the door
one of the brake glass locks so it means
it can't be opened because before we had
just a push bar so it could be open
because it has to be kept open as a fire
exit
so now it has a lock on there so people
can't go out in that area after 11
because you slide it across
you have to break it to actually exit
so we know that the noise
the source of the trouble initially
has all been resolved
so that has been remedied and then we go
to great eastern road
great eastern road prior to covid was
not i would
respectfully submit mr chairman not
causing a problem
uh not causing a problem before kobe
lockdown the problem was being
complained of was the precinct
that's been resolved
now
after uh
lockdown
there has been some issues in relation
to
other premises being closed and
therefore people seeking a late night
drink at in premises
now we know that there are other
premises around we've given the names
and
and obviously we are one of those
premises that people have come to us
we have in july and august
dealt with a change in people coming to
us
now we accept people were queuing
outside because we had a limited number
of capacity
seated only
being served
and therefore it was a winning win at
one in one out we agreed with the police
that we wouldn't do that in future and
we had a meeting with them oh sorry we
had a conversation with them and we
agreed we would have no queuing
now the police
wrote to us
on the 21st of august you've seen that
letter
ensures significant management outside
after uh 11 o'clock
door supervisor to be accredited we
don't accept that a door registered was
unregistered the door supervisors were
registered
but what it is is because we didn't hold
a badge
or a license normally you'd have to go
to an external con contractor that has
been resolved because now william ward
has a badge so he can employ as an
employer so there's never been
unlicensed doormen so let me just
clarify that mr chairman
in relation to cueing let them that
cueing could arise in effect from to
noise so that has to be managed
uh patrons leaving to advise to leave
quietly and disperse
and wouldn't be remitted if they in
future
clear and prominent signs to be made
about the above and take note of cue
management that is what the police wrote
a steps that they wanted on the 21st of
august
so we a client put in place
um two doormen on a friday after 11
to make sure they managed the queue and
people coming or going in disencourage
any queue taking cue at all and
basically said we're full now you can't
queue
made that clear on social media
and to take steps also to limit the
amount of smokers outside the premises
and that was recorded
so in relation to great eastern road we
accept that some people were coming to
us
because of the
other premises closed which created a
unique position but we addressed that by
putting additional doormen having the
signs and limiting the smoking to 5
outside after 11.
we made sure we took in all the seating
sharon we think we are managing the
outside area now and
september and october when we're open we
didn't receive any complaints we've not
seen any evidence of that from anyone
and we believe that that is working now
correctly now if people were going
across the road to roy's we would not
allow them back into the premises so we
would manage that smoking area but we
believe with the dorman there
that's all that's appropriate in
relation to noise management
of noise so we believe we have resolved
the issue in regards to noise in great
eastern
street
now
we've only got
to let no we we've got in effect two
households here so the way that the
environmental health present their case
as i say throw enough mud hope some
sticks we've only got two
we've got dorington mr dorington and
councillor cresswell there are no others
that have joined in in the review
yes there are no others it's been
properly advertised we've only got two
now the complaint of noise internally
has been resolved we say we say we have
actually had um correspondence from
chris
um
crosswell
in relation to cornish sorry in relation
to the
conditions of planning the conditions of
planning are separate to the licensing
regime
and i believe that they are being
resolved
environmental health
evidence as you know
there's no witness statement
there's no statement of truth
and in relation to the um
officers observations
they have said
there's been no monitoring in the house
no no evidence provided in the houses
that front onto the great eastern road
that there's been no actual recording
and measurements taken or evidence
submitted
they do accept that there's been
evidence of logs and recording
timesheets but none of that has been
shared
they also accept that there hasn't been
an action plan
um and i would have expected an action
plan in relation to this premises if if
they
required it now um you've heard that
from the officer well
um they didn't want to cooperate was to
that effect
but you can see that in fact
it says it's their response and they
don't want to engage
um well our client has engaged they've
changed their head the hand dryers
they've had the noise acoustic report
they've had lots of issues with uh
councillor cresswell but obviously they
don't accept what councillor cresswell
has been saying
not and and have had concerns about the
truthnessness of what he says
and why can't they why can't they say we
we don't accept what this gentleman says
and have a sit down and have a
discussion the officer accepts that they
they there is correspondence saying that
they were going to sit down and have a
meeting the planning officer says well
actually he consulted with
um the the with environmental health
when i actually asked james buckingham
about
that meeting he said he didn't know
about that meeting that would be other
people but actually
simon simon bailey said he did actually
speak to both of the officers
about the meeting and they didn't
believe it had merit uh words to the
effect that it
it didn't merit
a meeting so they didn't proceed
and that's completely inappropriate
there should have been a meeting
or that the uh mr ward should have been
told that there's not going to meeting
have a meeting and why
now in relation to the
officers
environment health they haven't provided
any witness statements they've only
visited once
they haven't provided
the logs or reporting from neighbors
they refer to six neighbors but don't
give any details no witness statement
no no evidence of their logs and their
complaints
none whatsoever mr chairman
um and it says um
and when
when talked about a graduated approach
he says well
they have to sort it out for themselves
but as we all know good relationships
partnership you work together
and you try to discuss it and resolve
the issues
in relation to
um
writing to them they've only written to
them on two occasions only
setting out
that complaints they had one was in
january one was in march that's in your
primary evidence there's no letters
after that date other than the
correspondence that i've referred to
about the noise abatement notice
so that is in effect the environmental
health the environmental health officer
when i asked him about
um
what goes on inside so he said
and when you allowed james buckingham to
speak again
he turned around and said that
um
just look at the notes
excuse me one minute
he said
crowds have
drunks at the bar
that's what he said
and that it's become in effect a
drinking establishment
but i asked him in the question have you
ever been there in the evening he went
no
have you ever been inside no
so how can he give you as a professional
officer
evidence
of crowds of drunks at the bar
it's completely inappropriate that shows
there is a bias against this premises
like on the recording machine clearly
they've left to go back in the premises
they can't say that it's a bias
the whole approach
you know is let's get the police who
asked some questions about environment
help let's get the police on board let's
get the local police officer on board
because they've written in relation the
environmental health have written to the
police to get them engaged in this
process
yeah and we've been given that through
freedom of information they know it
so in relation to here
um when we look at the evidence that
you've actually got can i ask you just
to look please at the simon
mills
witness statement superintendent simon
mills the power of the pictures
which were disclosed
at
mmck 01
yes
you see that people sitting on the
chairs people sitting at the tables look
how many gaming machines there are have
you got that mr chairman
i have seen i've got it in front of me
at the moment but i have seen it i know
the ones you're talking about yeah and
then i'll be looking at again and
there's and then the next picture shows
uh of people sitting in the some tables
and lounge and you've got all the desks
there's no
um
as the officer said there's no
huge crowds um
drinking in effect at the bar in the way
he has described
and that's completely inappropriate
crowds of drunks at the bar
none of those photographs
uh the only one i can see is got two
people at the bar everyone else is
seated
there's not crowds of people at the bar
and you've got to ask yourself why are
the officers using this language
why are they behaving this way in giving
rather than giving
a fact-based opinion a professional
opinion on it because if he's never been
into the premises
and
and doesn't produce the evidence of
crowds
of drunks at the bar then it undermines
his credibility and the evidence that he
is giving
um
and and he goes on and on about your
committee being lied to look the
application when it was applied for
that is what was applied for and it is
principally a gaming premises you can
see that with the layout it's not a
nightclub as the police said and they've
accepted that's not what you would
expect in the nightclub all the benches
know that all the lights are on people
are seated
now in relation to the um
premises the police say
well look uh and i think the police
officer was actually quite
quite
fair in the round
because he he accepted
that um
that the premises would not be
stigmatized or penalized by ringing the
um the police and i'll be very careful
because we're not in private
but the premise is
he accepted the premises of acted
responsibly
by calling the police when it did
and it wouldn't criticize the premises
for that and he sees that as responsible
management he also accepted that the
police had not done a graduated approach
to enforcement in relation to an action
plan and and i think we all agree that
the police would have ordinarily gone
that route
if they so wished
but what the police said in their letter
was that they wanted stuff done about uh
outside area
um drunkenness and challenge 25
and that's all they said they did not
go into any details about
violence against the person public order
or criminal damage
in their letter
yes and and i
the officer said look i'm not looking to
close the premises
what i'm looking to do if it's open
later and because he understands that
because of premises changing people will
come in here for a late night drink that
it should have a conditions
appropriately
attached to make sure it can promote the
licensing objectives
but we are not
and we do not want a vertical drinking
establishment there it isn't there's a
condition on the license everyone is
seated we have very very limited
capacity
the music is very low and restricted
there's no music that will allow you to
dance there's no dance floor
and everyone is in effect seated in the
lounge on the seat area on the tables
it's low capacity um and appropriately
we've now put two doormen outside to
make sure we check with anyone coming in
it's intoxicated and they're coming in
principally to gain or if they're going
to have watch something they've got to
watch watching gaming with a drink but
that is us managing the property and
premises correctly the police
uh i i've been really critical of lisa's
evidence
and i i'm not gonna see summarize all
that again you've heard me before but
we know that the
officers accepted that there will be
matters that have been referred to that
don't have a causal link to the premises
that they have there's they didn't have
a proper police analyst to do their
report the re the police statement or
representation was not signed and have a
statement of truth
and that the officer accepts that there
are a number of matters that had no
direct causal link to the premises the
violence against the person for example
there were
six matters complained of three have no
causal connection one was
splitting at the dps one was a common
assault refusal service and the other
one was the assault of mr walt we went
through
now
in relation to the police there was no
action plan
they talked about a graduated approach
the steps that the police have asked for
i believe are reasonable and
proportionate and we have put them into
place and since we put those into place
we say we've had no further complaint
regarding outside area and it is being
managed responsibly you know like
relation to drugs because it's on the
public record it's now been commented on
by council creswell i better comment on
that now there are only seven matters
complained of
and all of them have been phoned in by
us of us
seeing people
or ex suspecting someone involved in
drugs and we have dealt with it
professionally and responsibly and the
police said that it was responsible
management of us of the premises and
licensed premises should not be
penalized or stigmatized for calling in
because it is about a partnership
working
in relation to um
the police evidence i asked you to look
at the calls or calls of link but as the
officer said they're not looking to
to um close the premises what they're
looking for is that now post covid 19
and the nightclubs are closed to put
some steps in place to just deal with
those issues and i believe the having
the two doormen on the friday and
saturday predominantly the matters are
arising in relation to those days and mr
wald has now got an sia badge and he's
been trained to
and that he always has appropriate staff
in the evening anyway but now being
assisted by the two doormen limiting the
number of smokers outside and no queuing
um mr chairman
i could i could go on and on and on
about the evidence that you've had and
heard
but in summary
we have had
you know in effect a lot of pity backing
we've had
two
full representations from environmental
health department doubling up on their
representation
but only one visit
and no witness statements
um in relation to residents we've only
got actually two one council living
further away that's not given evidence
but only two residents
um out of all the residents are around
only two so i want you to put it into
perspective and one of those residents
we say has not been counted with you
less than honest
and that the evidence is questionable
and particularly remember in your mind
that counselor said i'm going to revoke
your license i'm going to use my
influence to
draw on it and get you closed basically
by speaking to the councillors getting
people on board and rallying around
and then that's and and the police
coming back to the police additional
steps required in their letter
um i say that we should have been that
stage where we were sitting down
doing an action plan to deal with in
effect what is post-covered uh lockdown
in july and august that's what happened
we've now addressed it and there are no
further steps required because we've put
in place the two doormen
limiting the smoking which you can put
as conditions on the license
and that we the conditions offered by
the police remember we did write we did
write to the
council
saying that we have door supervisors
managing the queues from 11 o'clock
which we did we don't encourage people
to queue
we uh
we've given that message on social media
and that
the hand dryers and the cooling fan had
been addressed
so we have taken steps
to actually deal with the issues arising
i think it's about proportionality we
spent three days on in effect um
the the two residents that have joined
the review
dealing with their evidence and we've
put those steps in place already
so unless i can assist you further mr
chairman i ask that that's all that's
required in relation to this premises
okay thank you thank you mr dads for
your presentation what i'll do now is um
i think everyone
has had satisfactory
time
to uh say their side of it all it's been
three days
so what i'll do now is i'll do exclusion
of the press and we're going to private
session to deliberate
so i have to do
this
cases that the subcommittee
considers that the public
interest in excluding the public
outweighs the public interest in the
deliberations being held
in public it is resolved that under
section 100a stroke 4
of the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for item 13. on the grounds that it
involves the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one of
schedule 12 of the act on the ground set
out in regulation 14 stroke 2
of the licensing act 2003 here in
regulations 205
so the subcommittee will now retire with
the legal advisor to consider the
application and make its determination
and i thank you all very much again
thank you
so moved so we moved to chairman
yep and so yeah
uh yes
thank you but um do we
we'll leave this meeting and go to a
private session
um
cancer carpenter had you finished uh i
was just wondering if there was anything
else that um
the legal officer wished to say to us
about um the timing for our
determination it seems to me there's a
huge amount that we need to consider i i
think it's appropriate to go into
private session to consider that aspect
and then come back um once a decision
has been taken
care of
thank you
hello welcome back everybody um i'm
going to pass you over to the legal
advisor
david smith to do announcement i i'm
grateful mr chairman um you've all been
very patient i we're all grateful for
your time um clearly
the determination of this application is
covered by regulation 26 of the 2005
regulations
subsection 1 deals with a number of
situations where the authority is
required to make its determination at
the conclusion of this hearing
this particular review is not covered
under those
particular examples but is covered by
subsection two
which states in any other case the
authority must make its determination
within the period of five working days
beginning with the day or the last day
on which the hearing was held
the committee
have made clear
that
given the number of representations
which have been made to it
both in writing and also before three
days of quite lively discussion
it would be appropriate
for the committee to
be able to consider
all those representations
in such a way that any determination is
seen as a fair and and right one with
the committee having taken all
appropriate time
in those circumstances the committee has
taken the view that they will be taking
up the option of providing its written
determination
within the five working days
laid out within sec rule 26 2
which means by close of play on monday
the 7th
of december 2020
and in those circumstances
that will be when the written
decision of the committee will be made
known to
the applicant
responsible authorities
uh the license holder
and other
participants
for them to read
and in those circumstances that's the
decision with regard to determination
that the committee have arrived to and
in those circumstances i'll now briefly
mr dads
can i just say i i
concur i think that's very sensible
given the the weight of information that
the members have and to set down a fully
reasoned argument i will only say this
that if the members are looking to draft
conditions or have any um conditions
that they're proposing
that need
maybe the police or environmental for
ourselves input then i'm available for
that discussion before a final
determination is made should that become
necessary
i'm grateful mr dad for that i think the
committee would just like to make it
known that they have made no decision um
they will be considering all the
representations uh and i'm grateful to
mr dads for for your offer if that's
appropriate at that time i'm grateful
for that and i'm sure the committee is
is welcomes that as well so i will just
return the review hearing to uh
councillor newman
okay thank you david well i'd like to
thank everyone
present who's attended the meeting and
for their time it's been a long three
days
we'll give it plenty of time to look
into this and i'll now close the meeting
and thank you all very much
thank you councillors
you